If they don't fuck up,
I don't trust him.
My father,
my father used to say,
if someone doesn't say the word fuck or
if their name is an initial,
don't trust them.
Yeah.
That's a creepy one.
Initials are creepy.
Yeah,
but you never know.
It's like,
it's not a hard fast rule.
No.
I give everyone a fair shake,
but I'm looking at if they fricken.
If there all the time.
It's fricking this for Mickey.
Mickey.
Yeah.
I had that one time.
I've never heard that one.
If someone said make a motherfucker.
Yeah.
I wasn't happy about it.
Shut the front door is one like moms
like to do around their kids.
Yes.
I come from a whopper south philly
family,
so it's like a fucking Richard Pryor.
Seven fishes on Christmas Eve.
It was like A.
Richard is like him on the sunset strip.
He knows.
Surprisingly.
It doesn't swear.
Teddy Atlas.
I know teddy.
I,
I've seen you know,
animated it.
I don't have to tell you.
You get very animated.
But yeah,
he doesn't really like fricking this and
fricking that.
Yeah.
What the Frick?
He says what the Frick.
It's not.
Yeah.
You know,
also doesn't swear Henry rollins.
Rollins does not,
does not swear.
It makes note of it.
Note that I don't swear he,
I mean,
I feel like that happened in the second
half of his life because black flag
records,
not so much.
Yeah.
I think he's trying to,
uh,
get more people to listen to them,
like trying to be more mainstream,
but he's trying to eliminate the noise.
Sure.
In what he's doing.
He's a brilliant mind.
He is.
Yeah.
Unlike me,
I mean,
you're really Rogan.
You've hit a little snag here.
Teddy,
Atlas Jordan Peterson,
Shapiro.
Henry rollins.
Than this.
No,
dude,
I love your music.
Thank you.
Out of here.
Now you're saying you were saying you
know about fuckups before the show
saying I don't know anybody who's an
artist who doesn't fuck things up.
Like if you're,
if you're really creative,
there's something about being like
legitimately creative.
There has to be something wrong with
what you're wired differently.
So what we perceive as what people see
perceive as fucking up isn't to us.
Yeah.
So technically it's a fuck up,
but in reality to us it's just,
I'm just behavioral.
It's just how it works.
I just traits.
If you were working at an office in
human resources,
you would use the.
There's no way I'd be gone in like three
hours,
but before that I probably put a bullet
through man,
if I was in a cubicle,
just give up at that point.
Some people can do it though.
So people.
It's not a problem.
No,
I just wired that way.
But I knew from such an early age.
Now I'm not wired this way.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Me Too.
I was terrified of getting a job when I
was a child.
Yeah,
it's fearful.
But now what you've done though,
man,
it's um,
I've told you how much of a fan I am,
but I'm a fan of how punk rock.
You've built all of this outside of the,
what you were expected to do.
This show is a fuck you really.
It's just what it is.
You know what I mean?
This is the,
this is what happens when you don't
calculate.
Yeah.
Well,
there's no cow.
Just do what you want to do.
This is what happened.
When people don't have the balls to do
that.
It's a.
it's a little bit balls.
It's a little bit fear factor.
Gave me a lot of financial freedom.
Sure.
That was.
That helped too.
Sure.
When you radio news radio did a little
bit,
but fear factor did way more.
Just gave you.
Gave me enough money so I go,
okay,
the money part I got.
Yeah.
So now let's just have some fun.
Sure.
But look what it's become.
Changed People's lives,
man.
It's weird.
That's the weird part that that wasn't
the,
that wasn't anticipated.
It wasn't a part of the plan.
It was just supposed to be smoking weed
and having a good time.
Well,
you're not aware until you're aware,
until people say,
Yo,
you've helped me through
tough times.
This show has got,
you know,
I people tell me about your show.
You're like,
that guy gets you through the tough
times.
You know?
And that's what's more important than
that.
Well,
people need friends,
they need community.
And one of the things that this show has
shown by having all my friends on all
the times,
this is a tight group of people that
love each other and care about each
other and want to promote that way of
thinking.
Being that you can do that you can get
through life and all support each other
like this back stabby bullshit that
people get involved in that is so
detrimental to you,
to them,
to everyone,
to the sense of community that you
create around each other.
A clip of yours went viral.
You talking about just get the fuck.
Keep negative people the fuck away from
me.
And I had that around me and it was
draining my spirit.
You know,
one of the worst things,
but when you're living a certain way and
everything's fast,
same with comedy and you're on the road,
you're grinding it out,
you can always analyze.
You can always step back and say,
this is why things are fucked up because
everything's moving so fast.
You know?
And it wasn't until I took that time and
said,
there's cancers in my life that are
there.
They're basically their emotional
barnacles.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
And once you,
once you cut the cancer out,
you see how different things become and
it's a,
it's kind of,
um,
I didn't realize it was that easy.
Yeah,
you can do it,
but to them too,
it's a good lesson for them to be cast
aside and for them,
if they're smart or if they have some
awareness or some objectivity,
they're going to look at themselves and
say,
you know what,
I'm a fucking mess.
Like,
I'm negative all the time and people
don't want to be around me.
I was real negative when I was young.
So as I,
yeah,
it's,
uh,
it's not something that's
insurmountable.
You can get over.
Yeah.
And,
and it's whatever,
whatever,
whatever hand you've been dealt,
you have to realize the reality of
situation,
Bro.
There's people living in mud huts in
places that are smiling and the,
and I have the balls to be complaining
about your writing and not getting
enough sleep.
I don't like to travel.
You just really have to assess that and
say,
this isn't the way I should be thinking
or processing information because we're
blessed to do what we do.
You know what I mean?
You make people laugh,
Bro.
For living.
I know
there's also,
there's a balance that you can achieve
between discipline and the creative
people like we were talking about like
yourself who are just off hand tattoos,
wacky shows,
something about you.
People see you though.
What the fuck is this guy doing that
follow you when you're walking through a
store.
I know there's a balance between that
and then real disciplined people like,
you know,
fucking navy seal type cats.
You learn from them too.
Sure.
And you go well that you can incorporate
some of that into your life as well and
it helps balance out all the wacky,
creative aspects of it and it makes you
a little bit more productive,
a little bit happier,
little bit dead.
Prez had a um,
they had a song.
A discipline makes things easier to
great fucking salt is,
it's a great song because it,
it's real.
It really does.
Discipline makes things easier.
It Israel organize your life
like for me,
when I feel most,
of course,
you know,
because of how you live,
but your body feeds into your how your
mind works when you,
what,
when I'm bored.
When I was talking about that now I'm
horrible.
Negative years.
It was also dictated by terrible diet.
Terrible.
And you know,
not that I'm in great shape or anything
now,
but I've changed things and I felt it up
here.
You know what I mean?
That's what people don't think.
You feel it in your brain.
I feel like a different person man.
After I,
after I spar a little bit or whatever it
is,
feel different.
I,
I got more energy where you would think
logic would dictate,
you would get tired.
I'm like,
now I'm ready to write now I'm crazy.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Counterintuitive.
It is.
It's.
But it's um,
but again,
like you said,
it's discipline.
I,
you know,
it's,
my mother's making gravy and meatballs.
It's hard to say.
Mike said,
settle down.
You got,
you can eat that once a week,
once a week you go home.
Just go whole hog gravy.
That's such an east coast Italian word.
My grandparents in New Jersey,
it was gravy.
Apologize to everyone that's not in New
York,
Philly and Jersey,
right?
Barely New York.
It's like it's not Manhattan.
They'll fight and they'll fight you.
They'll say,
it's sauce,
man.
Fucking crazy,
It's not do this.
Yeah.
Gravies,
New Jersey,
New Jersey.
Like old school.
Italian soprano style.
That's gravy.
Philly's gravy.
Then you go south
of Philly.
Become sauce again.
Yes.
That's fucking good.
No matter what it is.
Good.
It's weird how like if you go to.
Have you been to Italy?
A lot of my families to lower there.
The food is fucking fantastic.
Next level,
but it's a different kind of food.
It's Italian Americans did.
Is,
is a totally different cuisine.
Yeah.
It's interesting,
right?
Is the meatballs,
the Lasagna,
they will put some shit in front of you.
You don't know what it is,
but.
All right,
let's have at it.
Yeah.
The Italian food in Italy is lighter.
It's a lot more fish and then you have
the regions.
If you're north of your south of here
and said,
Gee,
if you know it's,
it's,
it's uh,
yeah,
it's,
it is odd.
It was culture shock just to think of
what I've been eating for my mother's
food and grandparents and you know what
I mean?
And then it's like,
it's just different.
My grandmother was fresh off the boat
and she used to cook everything from
scratch,
tomato sauce from scratch,
everything to pasta.
She would roll the pasta herself.
She read everything.
She would make her own bread.
She would do everything.
Everything from scratch.
The bread wasn't all there was.
The bread was occasional because a lot
of the times there was a.
When they lived in New Jersey there was
a store that they would go to a bread
place that you would go and buy fresh
bread basically every couple of days.
Sure.
And it would go bad,
like within hours because it was real
bread without 8,000.
Now today I had a piece of bread the
other day and it was sitting on the
kitchen table for like a few hours.
I left,
I went back.
It was still soft as fuck because it's
all filled with chemicals.
Horace,
man.
Everything is now.
Everything is what it's like when you
realize that there's fluoride in our
drinking water and people are just start
right with that.
I'm not sure that that's.
That should be there.
I've read that I read about Florida and
a drink of water,
like the pros and cons.
The pros don't make any sense to me like
brush your fucking teeth.
Pitch use.
Yeah.
I'm not,
I'm the uh,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not the sharpest tool in the shed,
but I don't think Andre.
Well it's,
you know,
and then you get into all the conspiracy
theories.
That's when you got to wade through all
the bullshit.
Like,
okay,
it was a Nazi plot to soften minds and
it wasn't.
Or was it just like,
I feel like somebody just got a lot of
flora they're trying to sell and they've
got some sort of a deal with the
government that's put into the wall.
It's probably more logical,
but the thing,
the thing is with all that conspiracy
shit,
you have to sift through shit because
there are kernels in their problem,
but they liked that.
They liked the more ridiculous,
the more ridiculous the theories,
the better it is for them because that
it seems more ridiculous in that year
alone.
Yeah,
and Oh,
you mean they're like the government,
but whoever is dumped on the floor or
whoever they in bags of Florida.
Remember when your grandma used to say,
hey,
you go girl whose day they say that
you're not.
Who's they?
Who are they?
But whoever that is,
whatever they're doing,
the more ridiculous things seem.
It.
It nullifies some more realistic things
like pumping into food,
into cattle,
steroids in cattle.
Why?
Like for me,
when we were younger bro,
white girls didn't have fat ass.
Yeah,
but they learned squats.
You think that's what it is?
Do with cattle or.
I really don't.
If you think it's squashed.
A lot of white girls out there with flat
asses to this day,
they're just lazy.
All right,
I'm going to trust you because you and I
believe you.
You're a gym guy.
Most of what's going on with food is not
steroids.
Most of what's going on with food is
antibiotics because they're getting sick
from eating corn.
Okay.
If you watch,
um,
there's a great documentary,
king corn and it all.
It documents how a lot of cows have huge
issues digesting all that corn.
It's not a natural thing for them.
They're supposed to eat grass.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
The fuck up and make some quite tasty.
But it's really not what they're
supposed to be eating.
That's interesting.
I mean,
I guess I always started the chemically
speaking that that's what was being
pumped into everything now because it's
expensive.
They don't need to do it either.
Like in Mexico,
they still do it.
That's how Canelo got paired with the
clench and I air quote,
allegedly,
he got clipped things.
Clenbuterol came from mistake.
I got a fucking bridge,
but you can get it from mistake
unfortunately.
Oh yeah.
No.
There's fighters that say,
oh no,
I trained them Mexican.
Someone recently said,
I don't see this fight.
I said,
yeah,
I eat it.
And it's got cleanliness.
And they're like,
the why didn't you get popped?
He's like,
because I don't inject it.
That was his line.
Well,
without a doubt,
there's some shenanigans going on in all
combat sports and all professional
sports.
You get a little edge.
That's just the money involved.
Of course,
being able to,
you know,
and teddy loses his mind with that.
Rightly so when someone's that
passionate about anything.
I mean the guy is just like,
Jesus man,
like said treasure.
He is.
He's an American treasure.
Yes.
He was great man.
Stories about his dad.
You.
Did you hear it?
Did you hear the Pi?
Watched half of it,
but I read his book so far.
You know,
teddy bear.
Teddy was a goon man.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Well,
that's where he got that slice was
hanging in.
His face was hanging off.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
But,
um,
yeah.
Well the Jordan Peterson,
but I mean,
I'm in awe of that guy.
Yeah.
He's a really,
really fascinating gentleman.
He is.
He is just scary.
Smart.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
I would,
I would just crumble,
trying to have a conversation with.
It wasn't just like a nitwit you would
catch up.
That's what happened two days later,
my friends.
But the thing about people like that,
it's like if you are around a certain
caliber thinker than your vibration
sort of matches their operation.
When you're around people that are way
smarter than you,
you realize like,
oh,
there's some shortcuts to think and that
I'm taking.
And then there's some,
there's some pitfalls and the way I
analyze things and these people don't
have those things,
and then my vocabulary stunted.
Maybe I should increase my vocabulary.
It was just start reading more,
reading the things and that it just with
most people,
it's the same thing as with fitness,
it's amount of how much time you put in
for how long and that's the same thing
with your intellect.
It's the same thing with your emotional
stability.
It's how much energy and effort and
focus have you put into it and for how
long?
Yeah,
of course.
No,
but like,
like you said though,
to be around someone like Kim,
you're naturally going to fall into a
line of thinking where,
wow,
this guy's got his understanding of his
calmness man.
It's like,
it's just,
I can't see that guy being rattled.
I've watched the debates and he's just,
he's so confident in what he believes,
you know what I'm saying?
I started things through clearly not a
silly person.
I think I am.
So that's the problem.
Yeah,
I am too.
Yeah.
I'm a nitwit.
So watching him,
it's,
you know,
it's um,
it's humbling to watch someone like him
that's got it together and has that
level of understanding because I spend a
lot of my life trying to get to that
level of understanding.
So to watch someone that's there,
you know,
it's like,
it's just humbling to.
I'm just curious where he was going to
go because him being known is relatively
new.
It's not.
This isn't a guy who's been,
you know,
a couple of years,
right.
When he said what you would call like a
public superstar intellectual,
now that's a new thing.
It is really.
It really hasn't existed over the last
decade or so.
It hasn't been,
and now they're starting and I think
because of Youtube and podcasts and
things along those lines,
these guys are getting super popular.
I mean,
he's selling out places where fucking
iron maiden plays.
Absolutely.
It's crazy.
And he talks about the book is,
if you told me that,
that a place where maiden would sell
out,
someone will go talk to a modern day
philosopher.
Yeah.
I wouldn't believe that because it's
idiocracy now.
You know,
he only eats meat.
So he eats.
No.
Yeah,
he's on this carnivore diet.
Really?
No vegetables at all.
No salt in meat and water.
Wow.
Yeah,
he's so wacky with it.
He told me that he had like a glass of
cider and he couldn't sleep for 24 days.
Like he's not okay.
He's eccentric.
Like in a heavy way.
He's a,
he's a heavy guy.
Yeah.
But,
um,
it's,
it's a burden being that guy as a
burden.
Well,
now,
and I don't mean that in a negative or
derogatory way.
I mean to be that smart.
And now don't you feel historically
that,
that
they're the people who are the most sad
and broken and as they know too much,
there's nothing worse than knowing shit.
The dumbest people I know are happy as a
fucking man.
It's an input people.
Sure,
and it's obviously his level of
intellect is next level,
but even being a bright guy or seeing
just being a rita or or,
or reading Kafka and Salinger and
whoever,
and just becoming aware of certain
things.
You realize certain times realizations
are always the greatest things.
I used to teach that to kids when I was
coaching them.
When I was coaching a martial artists.
I would say,
you're scared because you're smart.
Yeah.
See these people around you that aren't
scared.
They're stupid.
They don't understand the possibilities.
You're aware of the dangers and all the
variables.
You've got to put that aside and just
constantly trade on your technique and
your task at hand.
But the reason why you're scared is
because you're smart.
Everything.
My life exists around fear.
It's not good.
It's not healthy.
I'm not healthy mentally because of it
and I don't know how to shake that,
but it's what kind of fear.
Um,
my father died when I was 10,
so I have the,
like Mr.
my mom's my best friend,
you know,
and she's 72 now.
So like just everyday is worried about
her,
about in every way.
It's not even driven by anything that
rational.
It's like she's sick,
she's the best,
you know what I mean?
She's 72.
Listen to Jay Z and wears Jordans.
Does she?
She's,
she's the best,
but it's just a long of course I to get
a video.
Yeah,
no problem.
No,
but it's fear of not having her fear of
the unknown.
I really,
I fear the unknown.
I fear what if this all ends?
I've lived.
I've,
uh,
my adult life has been what I do,
which is music.
It's yours has been true.
I don't,
but I don't know how to do anything
right.
I don't know how to fix the fucking car.
I was like,
I can't,
I don't know how to do.
I literally don't have to do anything.
But that fears for mechanics too,
because they're like,
fuck,
what if there's no more cars?
What if these electric cars come along?
I don't know how to work a computer.
Everything's going to be computer
controlled.
I mean the people's business.
Who can think about the poor bastard
that opened up blockbuster.
He's like,
we got this.
We got to go last forever.
Right?
He just spending money,
like it's crawling them one day.
They're like,
oh,
we got this,
uh,
this new thing.
It's called a of the apple TV.
People like,
fuck appletv.
Yeah.
Mindset going.
Michael.
Blockbuster is not living in a box
somewhere,
right?
They'll probably.
Paul,
you probably sold for smart and probably
saw the writing on the wall.
Yeah.
But I mean,
there's a lot of things that just go
away and people find a way to make.
Do you get through whatever made you a
successful rapper?
You could be successful at anything.
I don't know that I want that.
Well,
you don't have to.
Luckily I don't.
I don't want to be a.
I don't want either.
I don't want the.
The fear of not being able to continue
the way I continue.
I know again,
from being a fan how you look,
you do what you want.
Essentially.
Of course work is work and even though
we love it,
it's still working.
I think we both had people in our lives
that don't get that.
They think that it's what,
when we talk,
when you were in Philly,
I know people hit you up the day of the
show.
Can you get me to patches back?
But like it's a fucking body.
It's your job,
man.
It's,
it's how you,
you know what I mean?
Put food on the table and I think
there's a disconnect there with people
that don't live in that world that they
think everything we do is have a party.
I'm sorry,
it goes back to discipline.
We were talking about earlier that you
got to love it,
but you also have to have the discipline
to get the work done.
Of course,
you know,
of course,
but I,
I have a problem with people that don't
understand that,
that there is discipline involved.
They think that there's not that we got
lucky we didn't when we did and we
didn't.
We did get lucky.
We created.
We created our own luck though.
There's a little bit of that for sure.
We're lucky.
We live in America.
We weren't born in the shack and sure
there's luck,
but then there's also you have to put in
the work and you have to figure it out.
It's a puzzle.
It's just open ended puzzle.
You make what you make it.
You turn it into something,
but you did it.
You did it.
You started,
you got your shot and you took it and
had the balls to run with that shot.
Some people fumble the ball.
The death is a lot of fumblers out
there.
Then I fumbled a bunch to.
Do you just get back up.
I figured out why you fumbled.
I fumbled,
but I knew that I had to get back up.
These people found,
fumbled the ball and then go into a woe
is me,
woe is me.
The Universe is out to get me.
I can't catch a break.
This doesn't and that's all.
I can't say all,
but a lot of it is self inflicted.
Yeah,
it is.
Well,
instead of looking at that way,
what they should look at it.
Okay,
now I know how not to do it.
I learned,
now this is going to make me better.
You have to learn.
You have to learn from everything that
happens.
If you're not,
it's your.
My father would say it's not a mistake
if you learn from it.
Yeah.
You have to be able to look.
It's adapt or die.
Like what?
Blockbuster.
Right,
so adapt or die.
Everything's changing with us.
You know what I mean?
The podcast is bigger than shows on
terrestrial radio.
If you told me that back when I was
listening to the Stern,
I'd be like,
why are you even talking about the
podcast?
Could not.
What is a podcast?
How big could that be in your bigger
than radio?
What person?
Well,
I thought that when I did it too,
when I first started doing it,
I never thought it was gonna be a thing.
I thought it was just a goof.
I was doing it for fun.
Right?
Like I would respond to someone on
twitter,
like just fuck it.
Just have some fun.
Yeah,
and it.
But you,
you change culture.
You've shifted culture and how people
communicate with this show.
I mean,
you should be very proud of that man if
you're not already.
I don't think about it.
I think if you think about it,
you'll trip over your own feet.
I don't think about it.
If someone could give me the best
compliment ever and I'm like,
I'm a piece of garbage.
You're better off that way.
I don't trust Joe.
We don't have a problem.
They're like you were saying about your
fear of it all going away.
I think that fear is what makes you show
up at the studio 10 minutes early.
That fear is what makes you get out that
notebook and start writing.
Yeah.
That fear is what makes you sit alone
thinking about how you're gonna
structure this or you know,
write your next this or that's,
that's it's all important.
People think that like,
like a guy like you who's a successful
rapper or a comedian that's successful
that you just got no worries anymore.
That's bullshit.
I have more worries now that I've ever
had in my life.
I have way more worries.
The one I had nothing in my pocket and
high school and I was rapping on street
corners.
I think about it all the time at Howard
that and now I look at the worries I had
then and that laughable I ground right
crack at the shit that used to,
used to bother me.
You know,
What's interesting?
Could you imagine going back to the
first day,
starting from scratch,
knowing what you know now,
how much better you would be.
Right?
I can't even imagine.
Think of that in the future as of now.
That's a heavy,
that's heavy.
You know,
if I look back on yourself,
like if you're a 60 year old man looking
back at yourself,
you're like,
vinny had the world by the balls.
Of course the problem is,
um,
I have a problem with living in the
moment.
I'm always thinking about the
ramifications of that moment while the
moment is happening.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's,
um,
it's detrimental to my mental health to
think that way.
You know what I mean?
I know I can't,
I see people live in the moment,
I see people that just are able to,
to let things wash over them and I'm
envious of that because everything is
overanalyzing and every way possible and
it eats at me,
you know,
and,
but I think that that's one of the
reasons why your lyrics are so good.
It's like a person,
a person has that sort of the,
the,
this,
the over analyzing aspect of you is
also,
it makes you go over all these details
and find better hooks and find a better
way to phrase things.
And this is like,
you can't be complacent.
You just can't.
I just wish I could just only exist in
that place.
I don't think it works,
man.
Everybody that I talked to,
the successful is the same way.
They're all a mess.
Yeah.
What are we going to do about that?
I just gotTa keep fucking.
You just got to not give a fuck and keep
pressing forward and know that this is
just part of who you are.
I mean if we go back historically,
everyone's alone.
That was brilliant.
Atlanta and like,
look at all these,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm crazy comic that's ever lived on.
Craziest fuck.
I think Stan hopes one of the brilliant,
most brilliant minds ever bat shit
crazy.
You know,
he's a good buddy of mine.
He is,
um,
you know,
you look at,
whether it's Bill Hicks,
whether it's Louis,
whoever,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean,
Sam was the most troubled person.
Well,
that's my defensive Roseanne.
You know,
all these people coming after Rosanna.
I'm like,
you don't understand.
She's Batshit.
She's not just batshit.
She got in a car accident.
He,
she had severe brain damage.
Yeah.
She's on all sorts of medications.
He has multiple personality disorder.
She's drinking.
She's on Ambien and she's seven years
old.
What the fuck do you want?
Right?
They want from this lady you,
you spoke that way.
And so did norm.
Norm talked about Louie and Rosanna and
the same way you like,
Yo,
man,
she's batshit crazy.
First of all,
if you're going to her for,
for uh,
uh,
you know,
if you're going to her for political
discourse,
you might want to reevaluate your life
problems on you.
Yeah.
That's your fault.
And that doesn't mean either one of us
agree with exactly what you wrote.
It's just how she got there.
But that's also why she's so funny.
You know,
if you go back and watch Roseanne in the
early days,
that show was fucking heavy and it was a
great show and her standup before,
even before,
that was fantastic.
I put her in the top 20 of all time.
She was brilliant.
But it's also a monster man.
Like there was nobody like her before.
Like she was just as brash.
I don't gather five.
Yep.
She was like a man he'll like,
like a,
like,
like a world class standard.
Sure.
I mean I remember like when that show
came on,
just seeing that house as,
I've never seen a house like that on
television.
You know what I mean?
Like closer to what we knew then what I
had ever seen.
I my house didn't look like the kinds of
bees,
you know what I mean?
I was maybe archie bunker,
you know,
it was like a little bit closer,
but it's when people are batshit crazy
and someone reacts to that with
confusion,
not confusion with contempt.
I'm like,
you understand?
They're batshit crazy and it's part of
why they got to where they're at.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't act surprised now that someone
said something looney yeah.
This many years after.
You know what I mean?
It just seemed strange to me that now
you're blown away.
She's been saying bad shit.
Crazy shit for a long time.
I think it's also part of this new
culture that we have in where people
just,
they find a target and they attack.
Of course.
It's like if,
if you have,
if there's any sort of weakness,
like if you have chickens and one
chicken gets sick,
that's what that pecking order thing is.
Sean chicken doesn't feel good.
The other chickens,
they don't,
they don't like make moral judgments on
this chicken.
They just find a target.
So along with that chicken.
So they start fucking it up.
Right.
And it happens with dogs.
It,
it's a,
it's an animal thing in human beings.
We have to,
if we're going to be real,
if we're gonna,
if we're going to be compassionate,
we're really going to be compassionate.
If we're really gonna,
like try to engineer a better culture
and a better community.
We got to stop doing that.
I agree.
We've got to just stop attacking people.
Like she didn't.
I believe I talked to her on the phone.
Just me and her.
She did not know that lady was black.
I know that lady.
She goes,
she looked Jewish.
She looks like me.
She just,
when she said I believe you.
I believe her too.
I think she was just cracking a joke.
Fucked up on Ambien and drinking and
smoking weed all night.
And.
But no one cares what her intent was.
All they care is.
I got a green light.
That's a target we're going to go in.
Well,
here's my issue with the modern.
The modern left is,
is they taught compassion,
but they pounce.
It's,
I feel like a man with no country now
too,
because I don't,
I don't.
The modern left isn't something that I
gravitate towards and neither is the
right and when I was growing up and
listening to public enemy,
you know,
at the end that left of it changed.
It changed and I didn't.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And you and you have these people.
Um,
I don't know where I stand anymore,
man.
I think there's this rational left
leaning people that are against
discrimination and for welfare and for
food.
I look,
I was on welfare when I was a kid.
If people say I shouldn't be on welfare,
well what the fuck?
Right.
My parents were on welfare.
All came from a poor family.
So we had food stamps and eventually
they did better and we got off of it.
But if you want to tell me that,
that doesn't help,
that fed me absolute.
So how could I ever go against that?
And that was a part of my childhood.
I think all these things that people
want to associate with being,
you know,
like with left or right.
I think there's just a gigantic problem
with pink people being tribal.
That's what it is.
It's tribalism at its,
at its highest degree,
which in since I've been alive,
I haven't seen it.
Never seen it like this before and I
think we know why,
but.
Well it's facilitated not just by trump
and,
but it's also by the ability to
communicate instantaneously.
Of course,
without any consideration,
you can just tweet something or make a
youtube video about something
instantaneously.
Sure.
Roseanne's ability to tweet that.
Yeah.
That quickly with the phone is why
Sankar show cost millions of dollars.
People lost their jobs.
ABC Junk,
you know,
it's either going to do the connors,
guess what?
That show's gonna fucking sink.
Like the titanic course.
It's combined Roseanna Roseanne with
Roseanne,
right?
Three episodes.
That's like flavor free diet coke,
tastes like water,
just
have water motherfucker.
It's diet coke,
but without the flavor what?
It's true and I don't.
It's just,
it's,
it's the hypersensitivity and it's like
the ability for anyone right or wrong to
be able to say something right.
Then where you would have,
you know,
if,
if you're doing fear factor in rolling
stone interviewed you,
there's a thought process there and
there's editing and you're sitting there
and you're talking with a journalist.
All of that's gone,
man.
It's like it that that's what it's come
down to.
You know,
we're all,
we,
all three of us had phones in our
pockets and can see something crazy
right now.
If we stubbed our toe right,
studied y'all,
fuck this,
blah,
blah blah,
and all the sudden you had done your son
is
good in that because the tyranny of
these gigantic organizations like if
they were tyrannical,
if they did have an agenda,
if you we're trying to smear you,
you are fucked.
You had no recourse and they did that.
Too many people.
I'm sure there's unscrupulous
journalists,
but also journalistic integrity takes a
backseat to.
Because now they have to get clicks.
Like these people are real.
Journalists are fighting for their
lives.
Absolutely.
Because these publications going under
real journalism is almost dead.
It's not totally dead,
but it's bad.
It's hurt.
But like I was of Emphysema,
like Alex Jones thing,
right?
Whether I agree with shit he says are
not corporations shut him down and that
to me that's scary that the corporations
can decide what we are able to hear
really
well.
I was having a good conversation about
this last night with some friends and
they were talking about whether or not
things like youtube or twitter or
instagram should be regulated like
utilities where anybody can use it.
You know,
like you have the right to get the
power.
Like if you have,
if you have a house,
you're.
You have the right to pay your money,
you get your power turned on.
It's a utility.
Yes.
Maybe a channel like that,
whether it's youtube or whether it's
twitter,
maybe a channel should be treated like a
utility,
but then the question is like,
what is it exactly that is good enough
to get you kicked off?
Because I've seen some horrible shit.
I want people to read or written rather
on twitter that.
And they're still on.
I've seen shit,
whatever.
He's being,
You know why he was brought down.
I've seen people say much worse
was the sandy hook and it was that the
sandy hook thing was he said that he
thought that it was fake.
He sends disavowed that,
but they don't care if you disavow
things.
They have this thing on you now.
You said that the kids didn't die.
They definitely did.
Let's get rid of you.
But are you saying that people aren't
allowed to make mistakes?
Are you saying that people aren't
allowed to evolve their thinking?
allowed to say things that are wrong
because a lot of people say things in a
wrong,
but is it only things that are wrong
about children?
Like where is the line where lines are
anymore and I don't know who's the one
drawing?
Well,
it's these people that either are the
ceos or the stockholders or the CFO's,
whoever it is that that is in the
meeting that's dictating these
standards.
They're deciding these are gigantic
corporations that we were just talking
about this.
I don't think they ever anticipated
this.
I think when they made twitter they
thought it would be.
Like Jamie was saying,
it was a fun way to like tell your
friends,
you know Vinny Paz and Joe Rogan.
I go into the movies.
Sure.
And that's what you would do.
Twitter was,
it was just like,
I'm,
I'm eating pizza at the mall.
Yeah.
It wasn't anything crazy.
And then people started using as a
platform for.
I know why Sam Harris has been tweeting
to Jack.
He's been trying to get Jack to ban
trump.
He's like,
look,
he's like,
he's clearly violating your standards of
practice.
It's clearly doing that.
And he's like,
Jack just won't respond to him anymore.
Wow.
Radio silence radio.
He's like,
fuck this.
I don't need to deal with this in my
life.
I mean,
you don't want to do that right now.
Maybe when he gets impeached then your
band,
y'all read that guy's twitter.
The fact that he's the leader of the
free world is bat shit crazy with
losers.
Yes.
These are the fi world calls people,
losers threatening nuclear war.
I love.
Um,
my favorite is very sad with the
exclamation.
All caps.
Yes.
That's like my.
That's my favorite thing.
If we get through this without getting
blown up,
we're going to look back and laugh at
the trump days.
They're going to be fun.
I'm just,
I don't know how long we're end to his
presidency,
but when I walked by the TV and hear
someone say president trump,
I still have a little,
you know,
it might not be,
it might not be a belly laugh,
but I still crack up.
Well it's been two years because my lap,
that's how I know.
I know by Netflix specials because my
last netflix special was exactly two
years ago and during that special I was
like,
we are that close to president trump.
And people are laughing like,
ha ha.
I was laughing.
I was like,
I went to bed or whatever,
whatever.
Knowing that there was zero chance.
Yeah.
You know,
and I didn't think Hillary was a great
candidate,
but I thought of fucking cardboard box
would beat him.
Yeah.
I thought people would.
I think of him as more of a liability
than anything.
But the thing is this,
people in Middle America just don't feel
represented.
They feel disrespected and not
And he figured that out and tapped into.
I did well,
I saw Jordan Peterson say something in
this interview and it made me think
because obviously with joking right now,
and the joke about him and south dummy
isn't Jordan Peterson said the bit,
the reason he's in and the biggest
mistake Americans have made is
underestimating him and thinking he's
dumb.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Dumb.
He just does dumb shit.
Yes.
And he's definitely an EGOMANIAC.
He,
I think he has narcissistic personality
disorder and that's that.
But that doesn't mean you're stupid.
You know what I mean?
But he,
it.
He took advantage of exactly what you
said.
There's a big portion of this country.
You've been there.
I've been there.
There's where you're an east coast guy.
I'm an east coast guy now.
We're both on the west coast.
We,
because of what we do,
these are the worlds we know and what
we're surrounded by and that my father
used to say,
if you don't live near a coast,
you're a retard.
Don't have to come in the more than half
the country hates me.
I don't believe that,
but my father said that.
But anyway,
and when you go through the middle of
the country on tour and you meet people,
I've been like,
Yo,
I've never met anyone like this before.
Not In a good way or bad way.
You're not around them,
around them and they probably feel like
no one has ever spoken for me.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
And even if a dimwit does,
that's better than no one's speaking for
me.
Right.
That's better than someone just calling
them fly overstays disrespect.
No,
of course,
of course.
And I,
and when I was younger,
I did it too.
I talked that way.
I went towards,
we get booked or I don't want to go
there and go,
let's just use it.
Just,
um,
it's ego of being where you're from,
from the east coat.
Well,
obviously everyone on the east coast is
very proud of that fact that everyone in
the West is very proud of that fact.
You know,
it's just,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know anything about Arkansas,
you know,
and just not able to.
It's because they just don't know anyone
there all,
there's no fucking Italians.
They,
I don't know what I am.
I'm a while my family from Italy,
you know,
so like it's just not able to.
And it's being an ignorant American.
I spent a lot of time like that until I
saw the world,
not the country,
the world and,
and being on different continents.
It,
it changes your thinking man.
And you know,
the thing you were talking about with
Diet and discipline,
like you know,
these people run,
walk,
walk everywhere,
run everywhere,
right?
Bikes everywhere.
Mcdonald's is eating like once a year as
a crazy night out.
Like my son lives overseas,
you know,
he's had Mcdonald's like three times in
his life,
you know,
a little kids here.
It's like every day mommy,
chicken mcnuggets you see cultural
shifts and,
and why there's no,
like I've talked to people over there
who didn't know what autism was.
They never heard of it.
Legitimately.
Like what is that?
And I had to explain it and that shit
got me thinking too.
It's like,
okay,
well why?
Why?
Why is.
Why is that not happening there?
What could be the reason autism,
autism,
autism.
Autism.
Yes.
Oh,
the disease?
Yes.
Okay.
I thought you said an artist
or.
I'm sorry.
I was like,
what is that?
I don't know what it is.
Either.
Shit,
you want to let you.
You're looking at me like.
I'm trying to think.
I thought I was trying to figure out if
you met artisan handcraft.
Yes.
Autism.
Yeah.
It's that accent pro.
Sorry.
No,
but yeah.
Well you know,
it's more common I think now than ever
before.
But the question is whether it's more
common because it's more diagnosed or
whether it's more common because there's
more incidents of it.
Yeah,
there's a lot of questions as to why one
of the big ones is apparently older
people having kids,
people waiting and putting off the
children and particularly men.
Apparently there's a big risk for older
men,
older men,
a lot of times have autistic kids.
I have more than a couple of friends
with autistic children.
Me Too.
And,
and,
uh,
I just it like.
Do you remember when we were younger?
But I think like the first time I even
was aware it was probably the movie rain
man.
Yeah.
My being funny about two percent.
First Time I was aware they didn't exist
and wasn't diagnosed or something about
it.
I don't think they made it up for the
movie.
It's like the disease came along.
Right,
right,
right.
But,
but what happened,
what happened to Kevin is a chemical.
Is it people that were on drugs?
Is it things or did it just wasn't
undiagnosed?
I think there's a bunch of factors.
I think undiagnosed is one of them.
I think also the ability to exchange
information now allows you to be aware
of it much quicker because of the
Internet,
because people text and tweet and do
these things on phones now you hear
conversations about autism and all these
different things that you don't hear
about before.
And then I think it's entirely possible
that.
Well,
first of all there's definitely more
people show than ever before.
So because of more people are going to
have more incidences of all sorts of
diseases,
cancer,
whatever it is that the question is,
is it more per capita or is it more
period?
Because there's more people now I don't
know the answer.
Well,
what you said about more knowledge and
information,
being able to be shit.
I have a dissociative disorder.
It's called depersonalization disorder.
What does that do?
So basically I'll be sitting here
talking to you and I'll just.
My body,
my mind,
body and soul will remove itself from my
body.
I feel like I'm floating down over my
I look at my hands and they won't feel
like mine.
Do you smoke weed?
No.
That's the problem.
It'll,
it'll trigger it.
Well,
yes.
Alright,
now if we got high,
you float above yourself.
I would fucking take that deer head and
put it through my ear.
I was lose my shit and I'm really
envious.
I'm envious of how weed has helped so
many people and that it can help me.
Um,
what does it do to you?
It makes me be I smoked when I was young
and what happened was something triggers
a dpd and people.
It's a,
you know,
it could be a traumatic event,
it could be ptsd.
You know what I'm saying?
Gun To my head,
I would say it was my father dying,
but it
didn't happen right away because he died
when I was 10 and it started when I was
14.
I smoked a blunt and dust.
Oh yeah.
And lost my shit.
And for about 18 months I know lie.
I thought I was in purgatory.
Whoa.
How old are you?
14.
I was like,
I'm definitely not now.
I'm definitely not in heaven.
Whatever those might be.
Wow.
Yo Man,
this is.
So.
This is back then there is no twitter
and I didn't even know what it was.
I went to a doctor and told him what
happened.
He was like,
oh,
it was,
it was what you smoked,
you know,
don't,
don't do that again.
And they never left.
And then I get these episodes out.
I'll be in the shower on tour and the
Czech Republic,
washing my hair,
closing my eyes,
and I opened them and not know where I'm
at.
No clue where I'm at and I feel like I'm
floating outside of my body,
you know,
when you would hear the stories of
people dying in an outer body
experience,
that's literally my disorder.
I hadn't thought about experience once I
took Salvia.
It was like,
oh,
I was over here like floating above my
pulse.
Were you scared about myself now?
I was tripping balls.
Yes,
I get it.
I think.
I think it's it,
like I'm doing the Fred Sanford,
Elizabeth.
I'm coming to see,
hear those,
uh,
those drug stories where a guy gets
fucked up for like a year.
Those securities shit out of me.
It happened.
Mark man was telling us about that.
Like he did coke with Sam Kennison for
like a couple of days.
I didn't sleep and he was fucked up for
a year,
a whole year.
He heard voices.
I would trade being fucked up for a year
to do coke with Sam kinison.
No,
but if it was like it was like 18 months
in my life and like,
Yo,
how do you tell your Italian mother
that?
No,
you can't.
You can't keep your mouth shut.
What you.
When you come from that culture man,
like my family,
like old school Italians,
they don't believe in mental.
You have to see it.
They believe in cancer because they see
it destroy your body.
If you say,
I'm bipolar,
I'm depressed.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm diagnosed depressed,
undiagnosed,
epd.
I take medication for it.
If that still isn't enough for these
people that it's the shake it off.
You know what I mean?
I can.
If my father was alive,
he probably throw me up.
This flight of stairs for the immigrant
mentality and immigrant mentality is
real and I'm going to steal that because
they want no,
fuck it again.
If it's not tangible,
they don't believe in it.
If I broke my leg,
that woman would do everything for me.
If I'm in the middle of a fucking
breakdown,
she's like,
you want gravy and balls?
I'm like,
mom,
I'm losing my shit.
I need to be hospitalized.
Can Process and the best woman that I
love,
no one in the world,
more than my mother and she's no one has
been more supportive of me.
Um,
and that's rad too with the immigrant
mentality you think I'd get to get a
job,
go to.
And she was like,
baby you do you like,
if that's what you want,
that's amazing,
do it,
but you better do it right?
Don't do it half fast and don't bullshit
this drinking forty's and smoking
blondes.
Rap Shit.
Looks good in the video.
But you gotta work,
you know what I mean?
And,
and it's um,
the work ethic,
you know,
like Joey said,
the immigrant mentality,
but it helps you in other places because
when you,
when you have relatives that didn't have
shit and you know,
they're dressed in potato sacks as you
go,
Yo,
I can't let my father down.
He's not with us anymore,
but I can't let him down because um,
I carry his name.
I don't want to embarrass him.
I don't want to embarrass my mother.
I want her to be proud,
you know?
And,
and that drives everything man.
Like,
yeah,
I'm getting choked up talking about it
because it's like I do everything for
her,
my son,
and when you're driven by that,
it doesn't have to be a mama.
You're driven by something that you care
about.
It changes everything,
man.
That we have people in our industries
and entertainment industry that just
have this fucking sense of entitlement.
It's plagued.
I know,
you know comics with fucking sense of on
when they're rude.
When you go backstage.
I,
I know from how you are that you shake
everyone's hand.
Say how you doing?
Thank you.
When they bring you something,
please.
Thank you.
Yo.
People don't do that man.
I know.
You know what drives me crazy when they
don't do that.
A waiters,
waiters and waitresses it don't say
thank you and they don't tip or they
don't tip.
Well.
Last night the bill was a
30 in the bar and I gave them 2:30
and the guy like chased me into stop.
You made a mistake.
He did.
He said,
did you?
He was like,
Yo,
yo.
Did you mean to do this?
You took care of me on that man and I
know that people are shitting on you and
leaving a dollar or maybe not even that.
Same with waitresses,
man.
No one gets shit on one of them.
What are they going to like?
$2 an hour or something.
You know when you really appreciate them
when you go overseas and they don't get
tipped.
Yeah,
so those people barely pay attention to
those motherfuckers don't care.
You'll sit in Amsterdam,
they won't even come over to give you a
soda for an hour.
And in Italy we were eating at Nice
restaurants and the service was
terrible,
awful,
awful.
Because they don't give a fuck what?
Exact same amount.
Why would they act any different than
someone at Burger King?
You know what the lady said to me at the
restaurant,
she goes to this,
we don't include a tip,
but if you want you can leave.
And I said,
listen baby,
I'm going to leave you want care of us.
So we had like a little American
exchange then don't worry about it baby.
I got you.
If you set it up,
if there's a preamble,
then it works,
but sometimes you to do like when
they're sitting you down and say,
listen,
I'm from America,
we tip the tip.
I tip big.
Right?
Okay,
let's make this wonderful.
You're setting the Rogan precedent.
I'm taking care of you still take care
of us.
Yeah man.
But,
but,
but that,
it's just,
you know,
when a kid brings in a case of water,
I'm like,
hey man,
thank you.
I've had those kids say to me,
Yo,
I've been doing this 15 years.
No one's ever addressed me.
And I'm like,
uh,
that's awful.
A and M,
I'm sorry for that,
but it's not going to be from me,
but kid that brings the towels for the
stage.
Hey,
thank you.
Thank you so much for having us.
I appreciate you.
I hope we did good.
I hope,
uh,
I hope the bar did well because my fans
are degenerates.
I hope.
I hope it went well.
And I think,
um,
I think that goes a long way bro,
in life.
You know,
I don't want to get into like a Karma
discussion,
but I think whether it's a comic or wrap
up a metal band,
if you treat people like shit for a long
time,
that gets around Bro.
CORECON comic promoters know each other.
Music promoters know each other.
They'll fucking call and be like,
Yo,
this guy's a fucking dick face.
I get those stories.
You know,
like I was talking to a promoter the
other day and he was telling me about
some guy who was an asshole.
It's like yelling at the sound guy at
the sound check and yelling at the
promoter.
Made them fly to New York to for some
thing because the sound wasn't right or
he wasn't happy with something and you
know,
they have to accommodate this guy,
but they're,
they're shaking their head and then
every chance they get they're going to
tell everybody else.
Of course when Madonna he is and I
don't,
and if he's popular right now,
when he starts to wane,
those motherfuckers will remember that
now when dudes like me and you,
if we start to wane will still get love
because of the way we treated people and
that's reciprocated.
Like Yo,
maybe he did 5,000
people last time.
This time it was just talking 20 years
down the line or something and then you
only do half.
That's still going to have you because
of the way you behave,
the way you were raised.
Well,
it's also you got an opportunity when
you're interacting with people,
like if you're working with someone and
you guys are doing something together,
you've got an opportunity to just put
smiles on faces and they.
They put smiles on other people's faces
because of that.
Everybody's smiling.
Then you've got a nice trickle down
effect once community what?
It's.
It takes more energy to be an asshole.
It does for me because I can be an
asshole and when I am I feel drained.
It drains the shit out of me.
I don't feel good about it.
I just have a Tampon,
but wop temper,
but I try to curb it and I realized when
I treat people the way that they deserve
to be treated,
everything changes.
The energy in the room changes.
They might bring you.
I don't know if you drink or smoke
before you perform both.
Both.
Okay.
So if you,
if on your rider is two bottles of grey
goose,
you might look over.
There might be four just because you are
a sweetheart.
Not because you asked for it,
it just,
it's just little shit.
I'm not even saying it's a big deal and
it's life changing.
There's just little shit that people
will,
uh,
you know,
it'll,
it makes their day just by us being
polite instead of the guy that they had
the last night there was a ball breaker
and saying the sound man.
The first off,
the guy that don't,
you don't have a fuck with a sound man,
is that mother fucker will get you that.
Motherfucker's got a ponytail.
He fucking listening.
He smokes weed to the allman brothers.
He's been around the block and people
don't realize that shit.
That motherfucker is 60.
He fucking listen to the MC five.
He fucking did sound for everybody.
You and I probably worship.
He is not impressed.
He's probably pressed by you.
It's definitely not impressed by me.
A rapper from philly.
He don't give a fuck.
You don't want to be doing mike sound
right.
So the last thing I need to do is be
like,
Yo Schmo Hawk,
turn this shop.
You know,
it's mentality with a lot of people
adopt that when they become successful,
they want to be a prick.
They want,
they want to let everybody know they
want to be that guy who yells and rex
hotel rooms and you know,
that kind of shit.
Oh I do,
but,
but I can't.
I don't understand it.
You know,
I understand that due to weakness and
it's just they waited for so long to
make it.
Now they finally make it.
They want everybody to suck their Dick.
But do you think that things like that
can be controlled by upbringing?
Yeah,
they can be,
but it's my,
my,
I have.
All right,
so I'm ready to smash something in a
hotel.
I hear my mom to that.
To those that made is going to have to
spend all the.
You know what I mean?
She tells me when I'm cranky about a
show and I'm leaving for tour and
there's no sleep,
so you talked to everyone of those kids.
You sign every autograph and you take
every picture.
I'm going upside your head with a wooden
spoon.
Spoon still has the crack from my head
from back then and it's still the one
she starts the gravy with,
but it's so cracked.
But she said,
she said,
you are here for a reason and these
people look up to you and these people
respect you and you do your best to not
just continue that,
but to have them think you're a better
person than they already do because
that's going to trickle down and then
maybe they'll treat people better.
You said it.
All of this,
all this energy travels,
man.
It does.
You know,
if someone was in here right now,
just for all three of us will get
miserable real quick.
If someone was in here,
bitch,
everyone's out to get me.
You know everyone that's in the s,
everyone's fault,
man.
Except that type of motherfucker.
It's never there for every fucking
decision they made a self inflicted,
but they can't self examine and say,
maybe it's me.
How about just give me a maybe
motherfucker.
Some of these people I know that's not
even in their head.
It's all of us.
It's you,
it's me.
You didn't give him a break.
You didn't let them on this show.
Motherfucker.
Maybe it's you.
Maybe your energy is also our
responsibility to castle's people aside.
Agreed.
There's a lesson.
Agreed and that's what tribes would do,
but when you're talking about a lesson,
I think when you're too deep into it,
you're not learning.
I think when you hit a certain
age and you're still like that,
I think you're done.
Some people,
I just think you're done.
I know that's a negative way and we're
talking about not being negative,
but sometimes just reality's reality
being pragmatic and you want to talk
about like good use of your time.
Yeah.
You're not going to fix a 45 year old
guy complains every day and that's about
a 25 year old kid might be going through
some shit.
It could be a breakup,
a loss of a parent,
that pattern that they're in this
pattern and you have to break patterns
and if you don't break them,
you end up being that 45 year old.
I was a shitty friend to people.
Man,
I'm,
I've always been loved and like in my
twenties and shit,
I was just selfish,
like nothing crazy.
I never did anything like horrible to
someone but just I thought about myself
first and I was probably like not maybe
the best friend is some of these people
and they're still in my life and I had
to make a conscious effort to,
to,
to evolve,
to evolve and break patterns,
man and breaking patterns.
It's hard as fuck.
But that's part of growth,
you know?
And that's one of the reasons why it's
important to be around people that are
also doing the same kind of thing you
feed off of.
Yes,
yes.
And when you're around people that are
just real negative,
that feeds off of it to be negative as
well.
Yeah.
And,
and you don't feel the need to break
that cycle because you're around
motherfuckers that are thinking like
that too.
So it becomes this,
this pity party where you're all,
it's a circle jerk of misery,
you know what I'm saying?
And the,
and the circle jerk of misery.
It's just,
it's never ending there.
So anything that.
One of the things that really expands
your understanding of people and life is
just being in a bunch of different
places and understanding that where you
grew up,
it's just one part of the world.
Yes.
The world is this massive play.
Like I just got back from Thailand.
I was in Thailand the summer.
I'd never been around so many friendly
people.
Friendly,
nice smiling people that I think they
call it the land of the smile or land of
a thousand smiles or some shit.
That's beautiful.
But that's what it's like when you're
over there.
People are just so friendly and I was
like,
wow,
okay.
If you grew up here,
something about whatever momentum these
people have developed in their culture.
Their culture is like smiling and
friendly to each other.
This is a,
this is just the,
the vibe,
the way they do it,
but if you around some real,
I grow super shitty,
insulting,
aggressive culture,
then that would be what you had to adapt
to grow.
Philly was voted the most hostile city
in America by Time magazine.
Oh,
it's up there.
So I.
I always though recently what I said,
this is how I described it.
He said the very smart people who will
punch you.
Yeah.
Like it's a good description of Matt.
That's not a very smart,
very smart media of average intelligence
that will punch you.
But it's Philly's a sophisticated city.
It's a real city,
but they're all,
they're hard people owns man.
They're hard people that.
Look,
man,
we threw snowballs at Santa Claus.
Michael Irvin broke his leg and we
cheered.
Well,
the famous bill burr rant when they
booed and this girl went on towards your
Philly for 10 minutes.
Yes.
And I love dom and dom.
He did the same restaurant working with
dom tonight.
Are you the Ice House?
Yeah,
he's Dom's great man.
The best we eat at a place called
poppies and south Philly.
And I see them all the time.
He's a sweetheart,
sweetheart guy.
Great Guy,
man.
Legend.
Yeah.
Um,
I just saw him on the,
uh,
the Bruce Willis roasting murdered on
that murder.
But he's a great guy.
Uh,
but,
um,
I've been friends with Don for 25 years.
Have you?
Wow.
You know,
he's a Philly Guy,
right?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Um,
but yeah,
w w what you like.
There's also a level a guilt though in
cutting some of these people off the you
were talking about.
That's Kinda hard for me because like,
loyalty's a big thing too when you're
talking about all these,
tell them these things,
but they don't listen to.
Then you got to tell them again.
Then they don't listen.
Then you got to cut them off and he
goes,
look,
I told you that's what's happening now.
But I still,
it eats at me.
I feel bad.
Like I should be like a savior complex.
You know what I'm saying?
I know that I don't want anyone to be
fucked up man.
And I have a hard time being like,
Yo,
this person is detrimental.
And they,
there,
my energy is fucked up with them being
in my life,
but when it's time to cut them off,
I still feel like,
am I being a shitty person by doing
that?
Yeah.
Well that's what they want you to think
because they don't take care of
themselves.
Right?
But you got to take care of yourself
before I take care of you.
I mean,
you got to at least want to help you if
you want to.
But if you're not taking care of
yourself,
you want me to do it for you?
Hey,
hey.
Hey.
You gotta get your own shit together
first.
Yeah.
At least make an attempt.
You can't just ask everybody to carry
your bags like,
come on.
They want you to carry their emotional
bags all the time.
And,
and again,
like I said,
if there's no,
there's no introspection,
there is no,
well maybe this many years and all of
this should happen to me.
Maybe it's me and I'm a dead when you
can't see that.
I feel like,
I don't know man.
I call them people lost causes.
It seems very dark and grim,
but I think they exist.
Well,
I think you probably have this attitude
because your dad died when you were
young and you were left alone.
Yeah.
You know,
and I have a lot of that because my
father and my mother split up and I was
real young and I haven't seen my dad
since I was seven,
so it's sort of thing you'd be feeling
abandoned.
I don't want to leave anybody behind.
So I always rescued stray dogs and feral
cats and took his crazy friends and
this.
My whole life has been like that you
making in the misfits and your father
made that decision and that weighs on
you.
And my father made the decision to die.
He had three.
He had bypass surgeries.
They told them to stop smoking,
stop doing this,
stop doing that.
He had my older brother cigarettes to
the hospital.
He drug the ivy down to the bathroom and
was smoking out of the window.
He,
he had a young son and made a choice not
to live for.
My other brothers are 11 and 12 years
older,
so they got them for 21 and 22.
You know what I mean?
Like it bro.
I can't remember his voice.
You know what I mean?
And that shit was heavy because you,
it's like,
did he not love me enough to live for
me?
You know?
And those things manifest themselves in
different ways.
As you get older you don't even know
you're not.
You know what's crazy?
It's a gift in some ways and the gift
and the curse,
the gift is that you,
you have this energy that comes from
this lack of this lack of something in
your life.
You're young.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
this is something I struggled with with
my kids because I try to keep my kids
everything.
Always give them love.
Always your hug,
kiss all the time,
make sure they know we were talking
about this answer.
All my friends that are interesting came
from fucked up childhoods.
All my favorite friends are my favorite
friends.
Their life was chaos when they were
growing up and they became these really
interesting people.
I,
I hate that.
That's what created us,
but you couldn't be more right.
I mean,
you're talking about your favorite
friends that are.
I mean,
my favorite.
Everything,
everything.
Artists,
painters,
musicians,
rock bands,
punk,
metal,
have,
all of them were fucked in the,
I don't know any well balanced people
that are,
that I feel like,
oh,
that guy's a brilliant mind.
He came from a two parent home in the
suburbs of Connecticut.
I don't know anyone like that.
Pressure creates diamonds.
Yeah,
man.
Bust pipes too.
It does.
Bus.
Yeah.
But uh,
but,
you know,
I wonder like how much of that stuff
haunts me and create,
you know,
like,
your parents splitting and being seven,
like how many of the fucked up things
that go on in your head now relate back
to that and you're not even aware
because the mind is so complicated.
Oh yeah.
You know,
when I started realizing that when I was
smoking weed,
I didn't really start smoking weed
seriously until I was 30.
And then when I started doing it and
then I started thinking about all sorts
of different patterns and while I was
angry all the time,
and I think a lot of it came from this
resentment of being abandoned when I was
young.
Some of your early stuff was fucking
super dark.
I mean,
I love,
I think you're a brilliant comic,
so I love all these ideas,
but some of that earlier stuff,
man,
that's pretty fucking and angry dark
place.
It was also,
I was,
uh,
that was also just a few years after I
was done fighting like I was a different
person.
I just had a different mindset.
And Yah,
that's a very strange transition between
competition and then stand up comedy.
It's just a very different kind of
mindset of I carried a little bit too
much combat with when you were still
fighting it.
We're still fighting.
And sometimes when you don't know what
you're fighting,
it's worse.
It's worse.
You start internalizing it and you don't
know what the war.
It's war with itself and the war would
self because you don't,
you wanted this needs this,
this energy needs to be channeled and
how can it be and you and you went back
shit on the knife and went really dark
with it and I've done that too.
But for us to be healthy.
His.
The other question though,
if we were to get healthy,
what?
We just suck.
Yeah.
Well I used to worry about that when I
was young.
I used to worry about being.
My idea was that if I became somehow,
you know,
air quote enlightened,
right?
Because I wouldn't be funny anymore.
Right?
Because all the funny people I knew were
fucked.
Of course I don't want that.
I needed to be a drug addict.
I'm like,
damn,
Kennedy was a drug addict prior with a
drug addict.
Maybe I need to look at these people.
I mean historically you look at Hendrix,
look at,
you know what I mean?
Look at look at Bacara.
Janis Joplin.
Yes.
Because he's a fucking mess.
The town drunk and one of the best.
So I thought and think the same way.
I'm like,
I might need to pick up a habit.
Just drink.
Yeah,
I shouldn't.
I drank a lot and had an epiphany.
I woke up one day and cold Turkey.
That really?
Yeah.
I drank a lot for a lot of years.
And now you don't drink it or it's just
like cash a little bit,
little bit,
little bit.
But uh,
it's,
it's more like when I perform.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Just loosen up yet.
But I was drinking two bottles of grey
goose alone every night.
Oh yeah.
Alone though.
Every night.
Seven days a week.
That's a lot.
Two bottles to the head.
That's a Bert Kreischer love burt.
Love with the bird.
I know that he's got a bottle in his
head when he's listening to this.
Who Love the bird.
Yeah.
You guys are close.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We're doing sober October.
We're trying to figure out the bet.
Well,
who grants first?
Yeah,
well,
we're trying to figure out what to do.
Thompson [inaudible] got some great
idea.
Instead of a yoga classes,
there's some application that you will
find out.
Are you in on this bed?
I want money on this is going to crack a
joke.
You.
You're not gonna be able to do the pot?
No.
I took the last sober October off the
whole month.
Yeah,
I took the whole month off.
No Pot.
No,
no pot.
You don't believe me.
You out there.
You're looking at me looking at you
crazy.
I'm going to find the order here.
Joseph.
I don't believe that you were sneaking
the pot.
No,
it wasn't leaving either.
Already wanted to get me tested.
We went to a yoga class or put money on
it.
If I put money,
I'm getting blood work.
He's like,
we're going to go to the.
Took a drug test.
He said he's still going to do mushrooms
when he's like camping or some shelves.
That's okay.
I'll let that slide.
So this is what the fuck this thing is.
It is a um,
it's some sort of a heart rate
application.
What is it called?
My zone.
Some.
It's a,
you're aware this thing around your
chest and it registers on an app and it
gives you points for the amount of work
you do.
He and Tom suggested that we try to
achieve some ridiculous amount of points
for the month.
I was like 40,000
points or some shit.
This is it.
You got it.
Um,
I forget what the number that Tom said,
but we're going to have to agree on this
number and what it would basically
means.
You've got to work out almost an hour
and a half every single fucking day of
the month or no off days,
no off days or you're in good shape.
You can do that.
Yeah,
I'll,
uh,
I'll be all right.
I'll figure it out.
Different Shit to do.
So I'll run hills.
I'll kick box.
I'll do little Jujitsu on it.
You guys can bet on how long before I
die.
Well,
you work out,
right?
I know you do a little boxing.
Well,
here's the thing I did wasn't in good
shape as a kid.
Then when I got wrapped money,
I did the dumb thing and turn into a fat
pig.
You know,
so late past maybe years,
I,
you know,
a couple of years,
maybe 18 months.
I'm back boxing again.
So you just regular hitting the bag,
hitting the back cardio,
skipping rope.
I know you're a giant boxing fan.
Yeah,
like obsessive.
me too.
Yeah,
I know you are.
Yeah.
You are.
Uh,
I liked your posts on Canelo Alvarez
triple g to casual boxy fails or the
worst.
I mean I don't,
it's like,
it's,
it's really like child molesters,
like under,
like the other one.
The other word like pedophiles are the
worst and then casual boxing fans.
Yeah.
It's the same with them and make sure
those kids hate me.
They just yell at me that I should watch
what I post.
Something about boxing,
watch mma,
faggot.
And I'm like,
oh man.
Yeah.
And all aggro towards me.
Well how come you could be a soccer fan
but you can't be a boxing fan?
Yeah.
I don't know man.
How come you can be a basketball fan?
Can't be a box.
The hostility is there,
man.
Well the,
the stupid conflict between MMA and
boxing,
I think it's stupid.
It's,
it's,
it's a deal to a lot of people,
you know what I mean?
It's so stupid because so many MMA
fighters have learned from boxer.
Absolutely.
Seniors.
Sure.
Yeah.
Max,
a friend of mine and he's a,
he's a big,
huge box and we would train a wild card.
He's one of the rare Mac Dan's.
He goes one of the rare vegans that
competed successfully for a long period
of time.
One of the rare ones.
Yeah,
he's a smart guy.
Very,
very bright,
but yeah,
I really watched his diet correctly and
made sure they got the proper foods and
fatty acids and different things.
Yeah,
I couldn't do it.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean for him it was a,
in his mind it was an ethical choice.
I know there's a lot of other ones that
are vegetarians and do really well.
Like jake shields.
He's a vegetarian,
but he eats eggs and milk and cheese and
things along those lines.
But you want your own stuff.
Yeah.
Do you enjoy that?
I do,
yeah.
Yeah.
But how did you,
like,
how do you learn that process of what
you do after the animal?
Like,
yeah,
I got lucky that I learned from people
that know what they're doing,
but Steve Rinella,
who's a good friend of mine took me for
the first time on a television show.
So the first time I ever wanted was on
tv,
which is kind of nerve wracking.
Sure.
You don't want to fuck up and wound an
animal and television.
Um,
but,
but what it is to me,
it's like I saw so many videos,
I saw so many of those factory farming
videos and I don't want to be a part of
this too.
So I was either going to be a
vegetarian,
which I tried to be when I was fighting.
I was trying to stay at a lower weight
class and I was a vegetarian for awhile.
I felt like shit.
And then I probably was doing it wrong.
If you're ready to scream at your
keyboard right now,
you know,
that's what they're doing right now.
You can plant power,
plant based path.
You're going to get bombarded.
But,
um,
when I started eating meat again,
I went up a weight class and that's,
I became much better and I just,
my body just reacts better with me too.
Yeah.
Yeah,
me too.
I like,
I tried it too,
you know what I mean?
Um,
I just found that,
you know,
I'm making smart decisions.
Forget Vegan and vegetarian or a meat
diet,
just making smart decisions,
dietary,
these dietary decisions,
you know what I mean?
It was,
uh,
was the,
all the difference in the world for me.
And as someone who works out as much as
you do,
you feel better.
You just do.
Yeah.
It's not a lie.
It's not.
No one's lying to you about it.
You just feel better when you work out.
Well,
the thing about fighters and people that
are in competition though,
it's like if there's more at stake,
because it's not just about feeling
better,
it's like you have,
you have an obligation to your brain,
to your body and to your future to
perform at your best and your life.
Because that's not a game.
You don't play mma.
You don't play box.
Right.
It's true that you can die and people
have people that if you're cutting
weight the wrong way,
when,
you know what I mean,
because there's tons of wrong ways to do
shit,
you know,
we know that diuretics,
all of that,
you come in,
you know,
malnourished and someone hits like a
fucking mule man.
You know,
that's no joke.
No joke.
I mean,
if anybody thinks he play boxing,
watch Canelo Alvarez versus uh,
you know,
anybody where he like watch a watch.
Any like real vicious knockout of
someone's.
When he took off,
he took James Kirkland soul out of his
body.
How about Amir Khan?
Oh,
when we cracked Amir Khan with that,
right?
Yeah.
Boom.
I mean,
we go back to the eighties and Julian
Jackson,
we just separate people from the,
from the,
from Jude.
I'm Julian.
Jackson was a murderer.
He's the hardest puncher I ever saw my
light.
Here's Khan right here.
And Canelo Alvarez right hand.
See this is.
Oh good Lord.
That was one of those fights.
Were they short circuited,
right?
Yeah.
He doesn't know where he's at.
That's not a game right there.
You're not playing that up,
but Canelo is so much bigger than him
too.
There's so much bigger.
Yeah.
I mean he made 1:54,
but he's a middle way and Amir Khan is a
blown up welter.
Yeah,
but he just separated his soul from his
body right there.
Just fucking hammertime that.
He's the.
One of the interesting things in.
You put this on your instagram about the
first triple g fight.
He landed in a triple g and triple g
shook it off and kept locking tourism.
Yeah.
And you can see it in his eyes like,
oh my goodness.
Caught them clean.
I mean,
you're a fighter man.
You hit someone with your best shit and
they don't budge.
Yeah.
Especially if you used to take people
out.
That's what I'm.
And everything shifts.
Well,
that's where a guy like Paulie
Malignaggi has a slight advantage.
It.
He's very rarely knocked anybody out.
So used to hitting people and keep them
going.
Yes.
He got once he had bad hands,
so we had to change his style.
You know,
it's a box and just poke the jab over
and over and over.
Throw a right hand every now and then to
keep them honest with bad hands,
but the beautiful thing,
the Canelo did he,
he just,
he just paused but the jab just to draw,
just to draw him down and he came over
at the time,
at the right hand,
but yeah.
Beautiful stuff,
man.
Yeah,
that fight.
I watched it again after a teddy atlas
and I had a podcast.
I watched a triple g canelo fight again.
They,
you score it?
Nope.
No,
I didn't because what the kids were
running around.
So the eye test.
What is your eye tests?
Fucking close.
Fight.
Fucking close fight.
Triple g came on real strong towards
secondhand makes you want 15 round fight
is what it means is.
It does,
yes it does.
But again,
dumb motherfuckers would have
struggling.
Yeah.
You know what those 15,
like the duke,
the Duke who?
Kim stuff.
When Ray.
I think like a lot of that shit was
because of the 15 rounds,
you know what I mean?
Because of weight cutting back.
Then of course these same day way in,
which is a real danger,
but a 15 round.
I mean,
it's funny,
we watched fighters in any professional
fight in combat sports.
You see them gassing and like the
second,
you know,
Larry Holmes had tits and was going big
tits and he was going 15 easy.
It's crazy.
You know,
it's,
it's just the human body is,
um,
on understanding how to manage your
energy to,
of course,
of course.
I mean,
when you come out in the first couple
and you just letting shots fly,
then you danced in the middle.
That's not a shock.
Yeah.
That's,
it's,
it can work,
but when it doesn't work,
you're fucked.
Exactly.
Yeah.
When you ice them in the second you look
like you have a,
you had a brilliant game plan.
When you're Gaston,
the seventh.
People are questioning,
you know,
your ability,
your ring,
I kill your,
your corner to risk it.
It's a heavy risk to throw all your
artillery at someone in the first round.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
It's just such a fascinating sport.
I love all combat sports,
but one of the things about boxing is
it's a combat sport that has the longest
richest history.
When you go back and you can walk,
I mean,
when Teddy was here,
we were watching Max schmeling versus
Joe Lewis,
second fight and you know,
you could go back and watch some of the
sugar ray Robinson's greatest
Henry Armstrong man.
I mean,
you get to see the rich history of
boxing.
Then you look at Jack Johnson fighting
with those black and white films.
Jack Dempsey.
Gene.
Yeah,
man,
it's crazy.
It's beautiful that we have that.
Has the audience with hats on.
What was that about?
I don't know,
like the old days dudes all wore.
How strange?
Very strange.
I mean there's,
there's a,
there's a history to box.
He meant no other sport could really
come close to.
Agreed.
No,
no.
I'm uh,
uh,
always have been a giant fan of boxing
before mma came around.
I mean,
that was really all you had to watch.
You could watch a little bit of
kickboxing on television.
Rarely,
but it was always bad.
Well,
the other thing was those guys were
superstars.
The heavyweight champ of the world when
we were younger was,
yeah,
like if we walked out on the street
right now and as someone who the
heavyweight champions,
no one knows,
some of them might say Mike Tyson,
but for the longest time the crazy thing
was it was a white guy and no one never
like everybody when we're kids wanted a
white heavyweight champion.
That's why they pumped a Jew,
you know,
Gerry Cooney.
So they were trying.
Tommy Morrison.
Yup.
They wanted it so bad,
you know what I mean?
But know.
But like those got like,
you know,
sugar ray Leonard was a hero.
He's on woman's Donald's commercial.
It's like those that,
those days are gone though,
you know,
it's become a niche.
It's now a niche sport again.
You know what I mean?
Why do you think that is?
I don't know.
I don't.
I honestly don't know.
Is it because people got tired of
corruption?
You know,
I be,
I've talked to teddy and fights,
you know,
not at length like you did,
but when,
you know,
when I go to fights and he's calling
them,
I always pay my respect,
but I'm not sure how or why or when it
shifted that shift from the eighties or
early nineties and then that's it,
you know,
it was,
it might go into jail.
I don't know,
was it,
you know,
de la de la Hoya was huge,
but I don't know.
I don't know why,
why these dudes were like,
you know,
the Ali was the most well known,
well known athlete ever.
Maybe.
Probably close to it,
you know?
I don't know who else would beat him if
Jordan by name.
You know what I mean?
What was really interesting was when
Larry Holmes was a champ,
nobody gave a shit because he had to
fill the void of between Ali and he was
between Ali and Tyson,
you know,
the tool,
the tool to basically transcended.
Meanwhile the Ali that beat the fuck out
of Gerry Cooney,
I would've loved to see him against
Tyson.
That's a different house.
I mean,
not Ali,
excuse me,
Larry Holmes,
and beat the fuck out of Jersey.
Came out of retirement for that payday
against it looks out of shape.
Still look good in the second round.
Up until he got what he was dancing
prime.
Larry gives Mike problems all day.
Yes,
a prime larry was a beast.
He was a special
fighter.
He had a tremendous job.
May the best heavyweight jab I ever saw
when he,
the the Ali that fought Larry Holmes was
an old broken down.
They shouldn't ever let that fight take
place.
A shell of himself.
It's horrible to watch.
But that Larry Holmes,
Larry Holmes would have given Mike Tyson
fits.
It was a different Larry.
Absolutely.
He was a monster when he was young.
Absolute Long Snapping Jab,
criminally,
underrated in history.
Eddy futz trained.
Yes.
I mean,
you know,
Eddie Fudge maybe the best train of all
time.
One of them for sure,
but,
but again,
like you said,
things at time and placement and
everything.
Music to comedy.
Some,
some,
some brilliant comedian slipped through
the cracks,
through the what was happening at that
time in comedy.
And,
and with,
and with Larry,
it's like Yo,
you came after the most popular fighter
of all time ever.
And before Mike who,
you know,
again,
two dudes who transcended the sport and
he beat up the most popular fighter of
all time and everybody knew it was long,
long over.
Yeah.
So he can't,
he wasn't happy about that.
And then he talks shit about Marsianno
which didn't endear them to,
that was a mistake.
He said Marciano couldn't carry his
jockstrap.
That's my son's name.
My son's name Graziano.
So that hurt one a little bit.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
Larry just just had poor timing
unfortunately for him.
Yeah.
You know,
he's,
he was very smart with his money though
because I still see him at the fights
he's paid.
That's good.
Yeah.
That's good to hear because you know as
well as I do.
What happens to some fighters?
Well,
didn't he owned like a Shitload of
things?
Easton,
Pennsylvania just took over eastern.
He did bought like car dealerships and
car washes and shit like that.
Yeah.
Larry was smart man and he's still talk
shit to.
Does he?
Yeah.
Like remember when he came back and he
boxed the face off a ray mercer.
He was older shit when he met with
butter bean and yes he is still.
He still had it and he's in when Mike
Tyson went to jail.
He's like,
as long as Mike Tyson is jail,
that's great.
I'll keep fighting.
It was hilarious.
Yeah.
Larry Holmes was something special for a
lot of people.
He slipped through the cracks.
People in the know know though.
That's what's most important I think.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
I mean,
and then Trevor Berbick fight Ali too,
right?
Yes.
So yeah,
or second to last,
but he was,
the Parkinson's was already starting
man,
you know,
because you think of him a couple of
years later at Tyson when Tyson be
Berbick and he was trembling then.
You know what I mean?
Like,
so that's.
We talk about,
you don't play boxing,
you don't play.
Don't play him in May if you know your
life.
It's interesting to that.
Ali,
you know,
I always liked to watch that fight with
um,
jerry quarry because it was after three
years off.
Yeah.
Man.
And you see his body looks different.
Yeah.
It just looks softer.
You if you see Ali versus like Cleveland
Williams and then he see Ali three years
later,
after all that time off,
he just doesn't look the same.
He was never really the same.
He wasn't with you.
When you think about why he did it,
imagine having the constitution to give
away the prime of your fighting career
to not do that.
It's very special because they want them
to fight in the Vietnam war is like,
this is a bullshit bullshit.
None of them ever called.
He said,
none of them have called me the n word.
You know what I mean?
I'm not going over there to do that.
They took three prime yet,
you know,
you got that window as a fighter man.
It's like four to six years and he and
half of it was taken.
It's kind of amazing too that they did
that and then they gave it back to him.
They let him fight again.
I don't know.
What was the circumstances like how did
they reinstate his boxing?
I actually don't remember.
I don't know either,
but I remember when he fought frazier,
I was like,
man,
I would have loved to see this fight
three years ago because he just was a
different guy,
but who's way too flat footed?
It just was a different guy.
Yeah,
I will.
The Joe,
because Joe and Joe in the Ali hated
each other.
For Real.
Yeah,
because he was,
you know,
I lead with saying horrible,
horrible shit.
He's trying to fuck with his head and
that's why I do it.
He was the original shit talker.
Do you think about it?
It's like you,
you,
you see conor and you're like,
that's highly.
Oh yeah.
Know what I mean?
For sure.
Like ric flair.
Flair.
Yeah.
This is a little bit of both of them.
They're too.
Well,
you remember when Henry Cooper knocked
down Ali?
That was like the biggest thing in the
UK.
I heard him bad and then Angelo.
Dundee cut the gloves.
Yeah.
I mean if it wasn't for that move,
Ali could have lost by stoppage very
easily.
Absolutely.
Got fucking craft craft flight right on
the fucking button and sat down.
He was on Queer Street.
Oh,
100 percent.
Yeah.
He had a house on Queer Street.
He was picking up the mail.
Here it is right here.
Boom.
Punch that again.
I mean,
that is a fucking picture.
Perfect.
Lefthand.
I mean,
looking at him right on the button.
He is staggering back to his corner and
it happened.
Luckily for him at the very end of the.
But I'll back then.
Right?
This was Cassius clay.
Correct.
So this is before he fought.
Was it before he fought Sonny Liston and
want to say it was.
It was,
yeah.
Whew,
man.
Who knows that cheated him though.
Yeah,
they did.
They cheated him.
It's different world.
Oh,
we got to change gloves.
They give him a long ass time.
Oh,
we gotta undo these laces.
Cut this.
Cut this tape.
Brilliant though.
Yeah.
Wow.
Hey Angelo.
Dundee.
He wasn't a newcomer.
No,
it was not.
He knew what the fuck he was doing.
He was great.
Yeah.
My favorite stoppage of all Ali's fights
is Cleveland.
Big Cat Williams because he hit him with
these just welterweight combinations
being he did it pop up.
Pop Up.
Yeah,
I mean he was throwing it really.
I never saw anyone throw combinations,
a heavyweight like that before.
Combinations like Ray Robinson and the
fluidity of this was.
It was one of my all time favorite.
[inaudible] Williams was a scary fucking
dude too.
He was a big puncher and Ali was just
lying on their body.
No one does that anymore.
Yeah,
and Williams just kept pressing for
pressing forward.
We'll leave.
Williams is a big puncher,
man.
He could crack.
He just couldn't find Ali and Ali was so
loose in front of them.
They look at that beautiful.
He's a chef.
Boom,
check,
left hook,
move around,
and then once,
once he started tuning them up the body
and then back up top is beautiful man.
Beautiful Man.
Yeah,
this is art.
This is art,
right?
It's because there was never a heavy
weight that moved like this.
People have to realize this didn't
exist,
man and rarely does exist.
The only guy who moves even remotely
like this today is Tyson fury.
Tyson fury can move.
He can bro.
Motherfucker can dance.
He can.
He dances and he's six foot.
What?
Nine or eight or some shit.
I think he's huge.
He gets clipped a little too much for
me.
He definitely gets tagged.
Yeah.
He got.
He got tagged by Steve Cunningham from
Philly and dropped.
That's the cruiserweight was even crate.
I'm like always Chin might not be all
there.
Well,
you know what?
Cunningham's a shorter guy and sometimes
for those really tall fighters it's very
difficult to punch down.
That's how Mike was getting over because
he was in the chest and he was real head
movement and the and the Pika bull that,
you know,
the custom model developed pulled up,
put the end of that fight up so I could
see the combinations that led to the
stoppage.
See once once he had williamson trouble
go big screen.
I mean even their bombbomb.
Bombbomb.
Yeah.
Like once Williams,
his face had been jabbed off and joe the
craziest thing,
a beautiful.
The craziest thing about him is everyone
historically has to sit down on their
punches to get leverage on him.
He did it.
He's dancing and yeah,
my mom,
bombbomb and.
Well he wasn't trying to knock you out
with every punch.
He was just cracking you papa,
Papa,
and when you're getting peppered,
that's fucking tough to deal with.
Rough to deal with.
It's frustrating because you're in your
head.
You're like,
if I touched this mother fucker,
I heard them,
but you can't touch her and you just
keep getting peppered.
Actually your legs start wobbling.
Fight Willie pep.
Yeah.
You know he,
he had the,
you know,
the footwork of Chili pepper and a
heavyweight I'm fucking hurt of.
That's another guy that people forgot
about.
Willie pep was one of the rare guys that
one around without throwing a punch.
Yes.
Like what the fuck,
man.
Unbelievable.
Anna Dego.
Yes.
Steve.
We got a lot of good ones back in the
day.
Maybe not so much now.
Joseph had Iran.
We had lamata.
We know Graziano well.
The community
got established as a problem.
People start doing well.
Exactly.
Then they get soft.
Exactly,
exactly.
The last guy we had was our total
godaddy.
That really rapid.
Yeah.
To really rapping,
you know?
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
that's how it goes though,
right?
The early immigrants,
the ones that get shit on there,
the ones who come up strong or tough
fighters and then,
you know,
now it's Cubans and Russians and yeah,
you'll come from that raw,
that Russian amateur program.
Like there's no fucking joke.
Right.
That's one of the reasons why I love
Loma Chenko.
He,
that guys you're talking about.
Yeah.
I haven't seen anything.
It's a maybe 30 years.
I haven't seen anything like him.
I work.
It's ridiculous.
I've never seen someone.
He's in a position to not throw a punch
and throws a beautiful three punch
comedy.
I don't even know.
I mean the,
you know,
they call them the matrix or high tech
to perfect names.
But I mean,
I've never,
I've never seen anything like,
um,
maybe um,
maybe a prime.
Roy Choi was different too because it
was technically awful.
He just had such reflex when they went,
that's when he got melted because.
Because he never.
He didn't Jab.
No,
he didn't do anything.
Right.
Hook left hook.
What rights from weird angles.
And it worked because his reflexes were
super human.
He was superman and then as soon as they
deteriorate a little bit and in
fighting,
you can deteriorate a little bit.
In baseball,
you're going to tear it.
Got Roy would really got Roy.
My opinion.
I'm a giant.
Roy Jones Jr fan.
He's my maybe one of my all time
favorite fighters.
What really got Roy's when we went up to
fight John Ruiz and then he went back to
tarver.
He was depleted,
depleted,
and I think when he went up to fight
Ruiz,
he might've had some Mexican supplements
in the system.
Wink,
wink,
nudge,
nudge.
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean he was like 200 plus pounds
two.
Oh,
eight or something.
Look good.
I think he should've retired after that.
Win.
Well,
he definitely should have consulted with
an endocrinologist and tried to figure
out what system was and then the weight
cut down to one 75 must have been brutal
because he was smooth.
He looked like shit.
He lost all his muscle tone.
He just didn't.
He looked like a shredded in the
nineties.
Exactly.
Yeah.
He looked like a guy who's system had
been shut down with the thing that these
guys don't maybe don't recognize if they
take some shit or if they,
you know,
even if you just cut too much weight,
your body stops producing hormones.
Sure.
Your body's all fucked up.
You're on,
you're on your way to die.
Body's telling you,
what the fuck are you doing now?
He
was 200 plus pounds when he fought Ruiz.
Then he has to cut down to one $75.
Yeah.
Thirty.
And who knows how sophisticated his
methods were.
I mean,
some fighters today are amazing at doing
that.
I mean,
they know how to do it correctly.
They know how to rehydrate correctly and
boxing at least has the,
um,
the benefit
of not having Usada in place like the
UFC does.
The UFC has a real problem with a lack
of Ivs and these guys can't rehydrate
correctly or the way that they want to
is dangerous.
It is dangerous,
but in their defense it's also a way
that they can detect a whether or not
someone's cheating.
Okay.
Because when they're using [inaudible]
you can mask a lot of shit,
right?
Yeah.
I didn't think about that.
Yeah,
that's why they do it.
Okay.
Yeah.
They just won't let you do it.
So when,
I don't know what happened with Roy when
he did put it in,
you can't take anything away from tarver
either because Tarver almost beat Roy
the first time they fought,
but then fucked him up.
Fucking flew his head.
Yeah.
And the famous words.
Any excuses Roy,
right before they fired or anything like
that.
He was so confident.
I think he gets his due either.
No,
he doesn't.
He doesn't.
He uh,
he had some great wins.
He had some great wins.
Um,
he's still at it too.
Heavyweight or something like 46,
47.
And he said he got popped for steroids.
So.
Well,
Duh.
If you're 45 and you're still looking
good,
there's something going on.
The only the only person I truly believe
in it.
I realize you'll,
you'll think I'm biased because of where
I'm from,
but I don't think Barnard ever did
anything.
I don't think he did anything either,
but narges just lives clean.
I've seen him,
uh,
order grilled chicken and get chicken
that was fried by accident and peel the
fry off of it rather than just go,
oh,
just this.
Once I'll do it.
I watched him take it off to just,
you know,
what it means to not eat that is just
insane.
Dietary in the gym,
you know,
I agree.
But the Joe Smith fight was sad to
watch.
Of course that was,
that was,
uh,
the Cova left fight was sad.
I was ringside but,
and I love Kovalev.
Yeah.
But it's,
you know,
officially legend,
like,
ah man,
this is rough.
You know,
it's crazy to see how deep into his
career he was still successful.
Like I wrote a blog article about Kelly
Pavlik fight because I'm like,
I don't remember how old he was at the
time,
but everybody had already written them
off.
My brother and I were there,
like Pavlics gonna beat the dog shit off
and on and gave him a fucking lasting
lesson.
He put on a clinic where people have to
realize he was technically passed is
fine,
is primarily fucked up.
Tito treasures.
Thirty 6:30.
It was 36 and 2001 that was two weeks
after nine slash 11 that fight and he
was 36.
That.
How crazy is that?
What was he when he fought Joe Smith?
50 slash 50 maybe.
Maybe 51.
Definitely 50.
Crazy.
So he was he.
I'd say he lasted 15 years.
Longer than.
Than the average guy.
You know what?
How about when he came back and boxed
Roy Junior?
Yeah.
Well Roy,
when Roy beat him the first time was
beaten him with all those reflex reflex
is slid off.
Clearly outbox the second slide with
just fundamentals.
Perfect.
Mechanical Roya didn't them.
He didn't have
them.
Yeah,
just relying on what was once there,
but it wasn't.
He was a shell of his,
of his form itself.
Well,
it was also the Glen Johnson fight was a
scary knockout.
He was on Queer Street.
Yeah.
Well he was just flatlined and astral
traveling after the got knocked out by
tarver.
Then there was not that much time in
between those two funds.
It was.
It was the next fight.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and he,
those knockouts where your.
You're out on your feet before you hit
the ground and your head hits the
canvas,
which is two shots and he stiffened up.
It was sad to watch.
It was.
I thought that was going to be the end.
Me Too.
And then he started fighting like in
Russia,
sanctioned over there.
And he's a Russian citizen.
Yes ma'am.
Bizarro world pussy involved.
He's got to have some toto over them and
to do that when you're talking about
Larry Holmes and looked up his
wikipedia,
his last fight was in 2002.
Again,
butter bean is 51 or so and he put it on
butter bean.
10 round fight.
That's crazy.
Butter bean can crack that.
Big motherfucker hit hard.
But Larry just snake that snake and
getting through that pop every time he
tries to come in and bunk by member
that.
But due to where those golden palace was
the first person he did it under Tito
fight,
man.
It.
Was that the first.
Yeah,
that was so weird.
Someone did it in the UFC to the.
They wore that shit on their back.
It's odd.
Yeah.
Put it on your trunks.
Are you going to do it?
I guess you don't get as much money,
but it's,
it is.
I Know Bernard got 50 k to put it on his
back and he bet it on himself against
Tito.
Real.
Yeah.
And you know,
he was a huge underdog.
Everyone.
Everyone thought Tito was going to whoop
his ass.
Everyone.
Everyone,
you know,
I was jumping off my brother's couch
when.
Yeah,
he fucked them up.
Yeah man.
Yeah.
Bernard was a special athlete.
He really was absolutely special.
Fight all time.
Great.
For sure.
Yeah,
definitely.
and it was interesting because I used to
watch him when he was in his thirties
and he would complain about crooked
promoters and all these things and my
thought was,
man,
it's too bad.
This guy missed his prime and then he
did what he did and then he did what he
did after the.
After.
Yeah,
because he got,
he,
he was in jail for like strong arm
robbery and got out and kind of like
wallowed in obscurity and then his shot
was at Roy fight,
you know,
and I.
and so we were like,
ah,
you got your shot.
I guess that's it just got better,
you know,
better with age,
just show man.
It's like the rarest thing in anything.
Well,
the discipline that he had,
that's what it's extraordinary
discipline in his mindset.
It should be a lesson to everyone.
Yeah.
You know the,
that the discipline and dedication to
whatever you want to do can be achieved
through that.
And he's still in good shape.
Amazing shuts.
The other thing,
he doesn't say no,
never,
never.
I see him at the fight.
She's still the same.
Yeah.
Chubby now,
you know,
but I don't blame those.
Like when the ran got really big,
that dude was cutting when he was trying
to make 1:35
and all that and he just kept going off
because he'd like to eat.
Yeah.
Only for Iran.
Barkley at one 68.
It's a doodle.
Turned 35.
I remember when he fucked up David
Morris,
that was unreal.
What is this?
Everybody thought David Moore,
this young lions,
lions destroyed this old legend and
Roberta thumbed marines in my top five.
All time.
In any weight class.
Top Five.
Yeah.
Well,
I always tell people,
if you really want to watch Roberta,
you gotta wash the lightweight Roberta.
Well,
before he even went to fight Leonard the
black and white fights because if can
and most right most can be.
Oh,
that's beautiful.
Most people in America think of Doran
from like sugar ray on.
I'm like,
you want to see art and and just subtle
shit on the inside than he did.
He was doing before Chavez.
That little subtle shit on the inside
and picking off shots that people don't
know.
His defense.
He was eating none of those shots from
inside and then bang the body and all of
that.
That those fights were all.
Yes,
he was great at 40,
47,
54 60.
He did amazing things and again,
that's why he's in my top five,
but you're right.
If people want to see and watch those
fights at lightweight.
Yeah,
he came up and wait just to get paid.
Of course he could have stayed at
lightweight for a long time,
of course,
and just dominated.
And I think I still,
even now I think he's the best
lightweight ever.
Wow.
I don't think there's any lightweight
who was better.
Well,
he was added back then,
but that fucking dark Goti don't take
the dog.
I said once I'm on a post,
I said I,
if I,
if I'm in a dark alley,
I'm more scared of the rand and Tyson.
Really?
Yes.
At all day.
That mother fucker will do some shit.
I don't know.
Mike's capable of.
There was an interview where they went
to see him in Panama and uh,
he picked up a cat by the tail and smash
it against a brick wall.
Okay.
I don't want to.
I don't want to see you in and now.
Yeah.
And,
and the interviewer was like,
what?
Yeah.
He just grabbed a cat and chucked it
against a wall.
Look,
man.
I mean,
look,
there's a darkness to that.
Yeah.
You're not a,
you know,
a couple of sandwiches short of a
picnic.
Well,
I mean that you got to think about a god
growing up in Panama.
He did,
and you're fighting for your life.
No rugs,
no floor mudding.
Yeah.
That,
that's,
that's another,
that's another level of poverty that we
don't get.
Like when you say the very first thing
you said in this interview where we were
born in America,
we already had that one step above all
these,
you know what I mean?
These,
you're talking about Castro's Cuba.
Like he wouldn't let those amateurs
leave Bro.
They had to escape.
All those dudes had to escape every
Salon de Lata at his family's dead,
Bro.
Like people.
These dudes to leave their family when a
fucking boat.
Not a boat on a fucking raft.
Yup.
He,
because Castro's like,
no,
we want to build the amateur program.
That's why Oregon,
the I like,
he's got dudes and two Olympics.
You know,
you try to make it the one and then go
pro and he won't let them,
the program.
It's so,
you know,
I don't know if his son.
It seems like there's a shift.
There's a shift culturally.
Romero comeback.
Yeah.
Yoel Romero went back and he was hanging
out there,
but he said it was very tense,
like you don't talk,
you don't say nothing really.
He's like,
yeah.
He goes,
because everybody's jealous.
They're all mad that you get to come
back and forth because,
you know,
Yoel Romero top UFC fighter.
He went back and I wouldn't,
I wouldn't go back.
I won't go bug,
you know,
if I had the life I had here,
you know what I mean?
And being a top guy and getting paid
days.
Yup.
Um,
I,
I understand why he went back.
Of course,
I understand why,
you know what I mean?
But if me and you go to Italy,
no,
we might not come back here.
Look,
they can have it.
Yeah.
They could have pictures.
So I got family and we got what's
happened.
Shit,
whatever.
Yeah.
I'm not interested in going anywhere.
I can't come back.
No Man,
but I just don't think we'll ever
understand what it's like to be
essentially a prisoner in a communist.
Dictatorship.
Absolutely.
Grew up through the amateur program.
When you all were married,
was on the podcast to Joey Diaz was
translating for him,
was beautiful and he was explaining,
you know,
what life is like in these amateur
program.
You are sharing time with 10 other
people that want your spot.
Yeah.
And that's what you're doing all day
long,
your training with 10 other things to
do.
And that's all they do.
It's all they know,
you know,
and,
and you think about there's no scenario.
I'm jumping in shark infested waters on
the fucking raft and if,
and if you're driven to do that,
whatever drives you to do that must be
fucking heavy man.
You know,
and of course we don't him telling you
that allowed you into the mind of that
fight.
That's a very rare experience that you
had to be that he shared that because a
lot of these dudes don't get to tell
their story.
You know what I mean?
Or what it was like and the amateur
program being stuck there.
Being a prisoner of your kid.
Once these dudes get out,
you know,
like they'll do some of them,
there'll be like a,
you know,
like there'll be an Olympic Games in say
Europe and all escape from there.
Yup.
They'll just dark after the fight.
That's what I was dol.
Oh,
that's what it escaped in Germany.
Okay.
Yeah.
So,
um,
a couple of people did it the same thing
like Russia or wherever they were at for
games and got the fuck out.
I mean that,
that,
that him getting in the ring after going
through that is cake,
you know what I mean?
That's,
this is,
he's living the dream,
you know,
training in a gym and sleeping on a,
sleeping on the bed sheets and it's
like,
this is cake.
Well,
you know,
that's the shit we don't,
we don't appreciate.
When I was talking about being a
negative person,
he was talking about near amateur
program.
If you do well,
if you're at the top,
you get three meals a day.
If you don't do so well,
you get to like,
you're literally fighting for your
ability to eat.
It's insane.
Like we don't,
we can't understand the.
Oh man,
not on any level.
No.
I mean,
imagine that's all you've ever known to.
Of course.
Let me see these slobs and America
planing.
Yes.
No,
that's how I,
when I started seeing shit,
um,
some of the places in eastern Europe
that were in part of the union yet and
in squalor and getting two year olds
asking me for money,
I'm like,
Yo man,
like,
get your shit together.
Meaning me,
Yogi,
Eli,
get you your way of thinking.
Change it because this is what this is,
this,
this kid's reality.
She's a two year old girl.
Her mom's telling you to come over,
you know,
asking me for yarrow.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a game changer.
How and if that doesn't change you,
that I don't know,
man,
there's your off.
The biggest mind fuck is that if you
make $35,000,
you're in the one percent of the world
when people talk about one percent as
you think about people with yachts and
private jets.
And of course fucking diamond rings.
Nope.
One percent is $35,000
a year for the world.
Yeah,
man.
that's,
that's sobering.
That's scary.
You know,
when you travel a lot,
like where's your favorite places to go?
Yeah,
I know you do.
Europe,
you,
you travel all over the place.
Touring.
Um,
I love Scandinavia really?
Is that.
I don't know.
I like,
I,
I hate the heat row.
Oh yeah.
I'm like one of those dudes with the air
conditioners on 24 hours and it's 30
degrees.
Um,
it's mega clean to super clear.
It looks fake.
It looks like a,
like a movie set.
Really?
Yeah,
but the crowds are crazy.
I mean I'm from Italy,
so of course I love that.
Australia was incredible,
but I almost had a nervous breakdown on
the flight because it's too long,
bro.
Flight Nav,
man,
Bro.
It's five hours.
Five or six hours from philly and then
you fly out of lax and was another 17.
This is a 17 that's really heavy.
If you leave from Philly it's 22.
Right?
That's.
Look man,
look man,
how,
how much does is if you go the other way
on the way home and on the way home we
were the farthest point in Australia so
the flight in Australia was like six
hours.
So from the time the time I texted my
mom,
I'm leaving to come home to
Philadelphia.
I got home 36 hours later.
Oh.
So they,
they offer me constantly to come back
and,
and you know what we do for a living?
We would go places and I'm like Yo man,
that flight nervous breakdown.
You have to decide what's more important
money or your mental stability.
Yeah.
And I'm already Nadia Than Squirrel
Shit.
So I don't need,
I don't need anything to push me any
further than
it's already what's going on in between
my ears.
Thailand is a similar thing.
It's like 14 and then another five.
I think it was like 11 to go to Europe
or where did we go?
I think we went to Taiwan first and then
it was another like five or something or
when.
By the time you're back,
you're so confused.
It took me two solid weeks for.
I started sleeping at night again.
I think it took me three.
I'd wake up like two hours later.
I go to bed tired as fuck.
Wake up two hours later,
wide awake.
It was two in the morning.
I'm like,
what is this?
Your whole Circadian Rhythms Jot fucked.
It takes forever to get back.
Yeah,
man,
it took me two or three weeks.
Two and I,
we fucked up my family.
We did two trips in the summer.
We went to Thailand and then we took two
weeks off.
Then we went to Italy,
so it was just a,
a double bunker.
So was it enough for you to be like,
I'm not going back?
No,
no.
I like it.
I've learned how to travel.
I blog.
I really like taking my kids places too.
I really liked the fact that I like to
expose them to places like Thailand and
Italy and take them to different places.
I like.
I like exposing them to Costa Rica and
we didn't get to do that.
Yeah.
So the fact that you have the ability to
do that,
it's beautiful for them.
You know that that's a lot.
That's cool shit to say that they did
that.
I'm enjoying it more than I ever thought
I would be an apparent to me is it's not
just a,
a beautiful thing to watch these little
people that I love so much,
grow and have fun and be happy,
but it's also um,
I'm getting to experience the world
through their eyes.
Watch them,
ride an elephant.
Thailand,
watched them,
watch them,
a zip line with me and Costa Rica were
laughing together on the heavy chain.
It's intense,
man.
It really is.
It's,
it tends to,
it's,
it's made me shift my values and shift
how I think about just experiencing
things.
Yeah.
It's a heavy thing,
man.
They change.
They change you in ways you didn't think
were possible.
Yeah.
You know,
empathy and not just.
But like you said,
seeing things through their eyes.
That's like the coolest thing,
you know what I mean?
Because we didn't have that.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's weird man.
So it makes me feel super vulnerable to,
you know,
like you were talking about your mom,
like worrying about your mom,
worried about people that you care,
but it's one of the things,
it's like a catch 22.
It's like if you're on your own,
you don't have to worry about nobody.
You don't give a fuck about nothing,
but you also don't have anything.
Right?
So when you have all these people that
you love and you care about so much,
then you worry about losing them.
It's,
it's a double edged sword.
Having,
when I was alone,
just wilding.
It's like I was behaving that way
because I had nothing.
So you're looking for something then
yeah,
find it and all you do is worry about
losing.
It goes back to what we were talking
about earlier,
like if you're not scared a little,
if you're not nervous a little,
if you're not,
if you don't get a little
bit of anxiety when you're not paying
attention,
but you're not living your life,
you're not seeing anything,
you're getting yourself out there.
If you're putting yourself out there,
you're going to have some anxiety.
You're going to have some fear.
You're going to have some worries with
those people that don't have,
that don't put themselves out.
Is that I live in a bubble and they're
comfortable and a gray and dry.
Yes.
It's that niche,
that Nietzsche question.
Would you rather live your life in a
series of tremendous highs and
tremendous lows or just flat line,
flat line,
and these people think flatlining that
square life is like,
oh,
you know,
two point five kids and a house like
this.
Is it like,
no,
that's not it,
man.
It's not.
I mean,
there's nothing wrong with having two
point five kids in the house,
but go do some shit and no kids.
That's what I meant.
Go to the woods.
Go rafting short.
Yeah.
Get get something done,
man.
We went whitewater rafting last year in
Montana.
That was shit,
man.
Glacier river,
fucking freezing cold water bears
everywhere and it's nuts,
man.
Wow.
Going rafting down the river and seeing
trout jumping.
It's like,
just get into the mix to see them
experience shit.
Like we took them to yellowstone,
they got to see Bison,
you know,
wild bison up close to their minds are
just blown by it.
I just want them to see as much shit as
I can show them.
I want them to see.
I mean,
I'm going to like every few months my
wife and I sit down and talk like,
what are we going to do this summer?
Like where are we going to take?
Like this year was Thailand,
where are we going to go next year?
Take them somewhere else.
Weird.
God bless.
Yeah.
It's fun man.
It's fascinating.
It's um,
it's a weird life,
uh,
education that I didn't anticipate.
Of course you build it,
man.
You deserve it because you did it your
way.
And that's punk rock and punk rock as
fuck.
That's funny.
Yeah.
When you're traveling,
how many guys you bring them with you?
It's usually,
um,
so there's three of us on stage.
Like me rhyming,
a hype man and a Dj and then a tour
manager and emerge guy.
So usually five.
That's a good thing because comics,
a lot of times travel by themselves.
They get the press.
I know,
I know like already we'll talk about it
a lot.
Just being alone in a hotel room and
fucking Schenectady.
I figured that shit out a long time ago
though.
I started bringing my friends with me
because in promoters or clubs they
wouldn't pay for the friend you wouldn't
pay,
wouldn't pay for.
So I would just say,
look,
give me a flat rate.
I'll pay my opening act.
I'll pay their airfare,
I'll pay their hotel.
I'd rather lose money.
Well my earlier tours I was the
promoters didn't care about opening acts
and I was paying my homeboys to be the
opening acts.
Just like kind of my what?
I was getting paid.
I was handing it to them.
The same thing.
User experience because you're keeping
yourself safe
and you have family in the road.
Like when I go on the road,
if I go on the road with Joey or Aria
and those guys were family.
Tony,
we're having a good time wherever we
are.
Like what time you guys want to eat?
Let's eat lunch at noon.
Okay.
I'll meet you guys down there.
And so you guys want to go to the gym?
All right,
let's go hit the gym.
So we're laughing and having a good
time.
But in the early days I did a lot of
those solo trips.
There's a weird empty feeling.
You have your urban.
That's a very dark.
I mean,
did you see that Louis episode that he
did about traveling and he's alone?
It's a whole episode dedicated to what
you just said.
And it was very dark.
It was not humorous.
You got to take friends with you.
I have friends to this day that don't do
it that way.
They go on,
they use local acts and I'm like,
man,
don't do it with A.
Yeah.
But then I'd have to pay for his air
fare.
I'm like paid them money or man,
I know you're going to make less money
that way,
but you'll feel better.
You have to,
there comes a time where those decisions
where you're doing things monetarily,
uh,
they were making this decision based on
financial and you have to worry about
your mental stability more.
Whatever the opener with Gat,
if it's $500 grand,
three grand,
$5,
whatever it is that's worth having
family with you,
and not only that,
I feel like your performance is going to
be better or worse because you're going
to be with friends or going to have a
good time.
You're not worried about the show.
You bring a funny guy to open up for
you.
You know he's good.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and then so then more people will come
to your next show.
It's like,
it's better for you financially.
It's a short term investment or for
longterm gain.
Of course,
of course.
That's what these people think.
They're penny wise and pound foolish.
You know what I mean?
They don't understand that when what
you're doing,
everyone's going to kill and then it's
going to be double the people next door.
At least everybody's gonna have a good
time and you're not gonna get out of
there crazy.
When I come back Sunday morning,
I might be tired,
but at least I had a good time.
Sure.
I'm not.
I don't feel like I'm going to fucking
shoot myself.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
That's the real problem with travel.
It's fucking depressing.
You know,
one of the things I read about,
um,
an interview with bordain after he died,
I started reading a bunch of shit that
he had decided.
It blindsided me.
I didn't see it coming.
And then after he died I read a bunch of
his stuff where he was talking about how
intensely lonely it was when he was
traveling and I knew he'd traveled with
people that he cared about,
you know,
he traveled with people that he liked,
but I think just traveling 250 days a
year period will fuck you up.
Absolutely.
I,
I can't say that bit at people being
with me.
I still don't feel lonely because
there's something,
there's a connection to home that once I
separate from that,
from home,
from Philly for my mom,
you know,
all of that.
Once,
once I'm separated from that reality,
it,
I love having my friends around me and
it makes it better,
but it doesn't fix it.
Yeah.
There's still the sense,
um,
I'm out here alone.
There's still um,
and,
and I don't,
I don't,
I can't make any sense out of that
because I'm technically not alone.
So it's not.
Yeah,
it doesn't make much sense.
Not home though.
Right.
I read something where you were saying
that this might be your last tour.
I'm just,
I don't know man.
It's,
it's common.
Yeah.
Hold,
you know,
four.
I'll be 41 in October fifth and he just
getting tired of it or ain't me man,
forget the physical training.
My spirit.
It's the anxiety before I'm leaving.
Is,
is a say you get nervous like three days
before you leaving now it's starting
like two months before I'm leaving.
Really?
Yeah.
Just when you go out,
how long do you go out for a.
that's changed too.
I mean I would go out for six weeks,
42 shows in a row before,
you know,
before now I got like two,
two and a half weeks and me then I'll
come home.
Then I got like when I,
when I come back from Cali and I go to
Europe,
you know?
Um,
but you know,
again,
like to say last tour,
it's like I don't want to fucking turn
into gene simmons whereas,
you know what I'm saying where it's
like,
this is it.
So come see me.
You're never gonna see me again.
Like I'm not doing the 19 eighties.
They did that at 83 or something,
you know,
I don't want to do that.
So I don't,
it's why I chose my words properly where
it was more like,
you know,
I'm getting run down and it's,
traveling is,
is,
uh,
it's a,
again,
it's no different than you.
It's beautiful being up on stage when
people are laughing,
you know,
but getting there,
the flights,
the,
this,
that,
the hotels,
it's just,
I don't,
you know,
it's something that you could never
explain to someone who doesn't do it
and,
and why exactly.
You're tired still when you walk out on
stage and Germany or some shit goes away
and everybody goes crazy.
It all goes away.
It's still a side of the planet,
other side of the planet.
It's still,
it's still the most humbling thing in
the world because it's still in my head,
like,
no,
I'm a kid from Philly,
you know,
like it was rhyming on street corners,
gentlemen,
Finny Past.
Yeah.
That could never.
It's crazy.
Never not feel great.
You know,
it's um,
I almost feel bad for people that will
never experience it.
I sure.
Sure.
It's a mind fuck of unreal.
It's like pinch yourself shit.
Yeah.
You know,
he was like,
well,
we'll have a fuck.
Did they?
Sometimes you got to step back.
You know,
I don't think as people we do that
enough,
you know,
because we were living in the moment,
like even right now it's like I've been
a fan of yours for a very long time and
just to have this convo with you is
beautiful and it's going to be a mind
fuck later after I think about it.
Right.
You know what I mean?
We was talking like old friends now,
you know what I mean?
But it's like for I've been following
your whole career,
you know what I mean?
So,
and it had been a fan your whole career.
So it's,
I still get weirded out when I meet
people,
of course,
knowing someone for a long time for
watching stuff or listening to this
stuff and then you're right in front of
him.
Like,
hey man.
He like I became friends with Bill
Paxton because he like was like,
can I would kind come to the show.
I'm a fan or why?
That guy was great.
He was the best.
He doesn't know what I loved him in.
Remember that vampire movie?
Oh Shit the fuck was that movie?
I remember what that was called.
God Damn it.
Did you see the Shitty,
the rounded frailty?
I did see that.
That was good.
That was very good.
Yeah,
it was creepy.
Very creepy.
Yeah.
What the fuck was that fan power movie.
Jamie's got it.
What do you.
What is it?
Jamie?
Near dark.
That was a great.
That's one of the best vampire movies
ever.
And one of the ones that people forgot
about Jamie's like,
Yo,
this motherfucker wizard.
Oh man,
he's not even finished sentences and
shits on the boys to what?
We've been working together a long time.
It's telepathic.
That's what's going on.
I can tell you how much respect man.
Paxton was in a gang.
Good movies.
Yeah,
man.
He was a great pro chat.
Yeah,
you're stupid.
But wide.
Yeah.
Aliens,
aliens.
The second alien member.
He's in the first scene of terminator.
He's the punk.
Rock is closed.
That's right.
Yeah.
Yeah,
man.
Talented guy.
Very sad man.
That guy went on fucking good morning
America.
Yeah,
it went on.
Good morning.
America and pick me up to like Kathie
Lee really was like,
I heard you're a hip hop fan.
He's like,
yeah,
Jedi mind tricks.
You want to talk about?
What the fuck?
You know what I mean?
I got like one sock on my hair sticking
up and saying my name on Good Morning
America.
How old was he when he died?
He was only like 60 something.
Yeah man.
He was young.
He died of a stroke.
He was young and man and not a dude who
like,
he was in good shape and you know,
lived well.
Six 62.
FARC stroke,
Jesus Christ.
They had a young son,
has a young son,
you know,
very young.
It's only 21 now.
Twenty two,
you know,
so that's.
Yeah.
You never know,
man.
You do never know.
You know,
that's a hard life to men.
That movie star life.
Maybe a little poor baby.
Two movies,
but those days are rough man.
Sixteen hours,
eight to 16,
18 hours standing around waiting and
then you got to do it again the next day
and you're working six,
seven days a week.
Rarely do you have a day off because
their budget is only a certain amount.
They get smashing all the 42 days in a
row or something.
Everybody's on.
Everybody's nerves are on top of people
and it's stressful tense.
You ever hear the Christian Bale ran the
sound guy or the lighting guy was in his
way.
You're fucking amateur man.
Losing loses his shit.
Yeah.
Well he's an intense guy,
brilliant actor.
He's a.
he's one of those almost die for a park
guys.
Definitely.
When he did the Dicky Eklund and Micky
Ward,
shit,
he almost died.
He.
That was the second time you did that
mechanic,
machinist,
mechanic.
Shit is brilliant.
That's not even a good movie.
That's not a problem,
it's just the hardest thing.
It's just the hardest thing.
Seeing him literally on death's door.
That's the brilliance and yeah,
I just don't understand people that are
willing to do that and just do something
else.
I'm not willing to do anything.
He only stopped a role where you don't
have to starve yourself.
Yeah.
You had to have another script in front
of you that day and it was.
That's the thing is like do that movie
and all that movie is known for is the
fact that you almost died.
That's it.
Nobody's like,
man,
the machinists was like,
like when?
When Robert Deniro gained a shitload of
weight for raging bull,
you know,
he,
he got in fantastic shape play.
Jake Lamata was ripped and then gained a
fuck load of weight.
Jake,
because he was older,
like you go,
wow,
that's some serious goddamn commitment
and it's one of the best movies ever.
Yeah,
that's the thing.
It's one of the best movies ever,
but if you do that,
like,
like charlene the Ron did that when she
knows.
Yeah.
That was another one and that was even
more bulk.
She's a beautiful watch.
Yeah.
So for her to get fat and disgusting
like that was like wow.
Yeah.
And I'm always great.
It was a great movie.
It won the Oscar,
right?
Or she did.
Yeah.
Uh,
I think,
yeah,
she got gross.
Yeah.
That's a horror movie.
My friend Patty wrote and directed the.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Wow.
The Jenkins in the house.
That's crazy.
We think about how fucking smoking hot
she is.
Yeah,
man.
She got girl rose.
Got rid of her eyebrows,
eyelashes or eyebrows.
Everything.
Look at it with that Oscar.
Ooh.
St Person Hollow.
She makes you think all those chubby
gross ladies.
Maybe just,
maybe they just need a little,
a little motivation look like charlene.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a tough craft that acting,
you know,
it's um,
it's one of those jobs where,
you know,
everybody wants to do it,
but very few people can.
And when you do do it,
it's such an unbelievably grueling
grind.
You can only do it for so long.
And if you're a woman,
man,
you gotta just a few years in your
window is very short,
especially if you're a hot woman.
Yeah.
There's a gang of those 22 year old
cupcakes coming up trying to take your
spot.
Absolutely.
Just as crazy as you.
They can cry on cue and they will always
be coming up.
Always.
Always,
always,
always bad parents out there making good
actors.
Absolutely making bad parental decisions
and sending their kids to Hollywood
being that's what it is here.
There's a flood of.
I mean,
how often do you spend time out here?
Pretty often.
A couple times a year.
I have a lot of like close friends out
here.
It's just a strange place.
Bizarro world.
And,
and like Philly is not a show Biz hub?
No,
but there's a lot of great showbiz.
Kevin Hart,
great bands.
Music,
of course.
Great stuff comes from philly.
Yeah.
But it's not a showbiz has not.
It's not.
I mean we're 90 miles from New York,
so that's like,
you know,
but not close enough.
But this is a show.
Biz Hub of course,
attracts all the weird everywhere.
I mean,
every weight is an aspiring actor,
bartender,
bartenders that I still through all the
times I've been coming here.
Can't wrap my head around that.
Like that.
Everyone's in inspiring somebody.
One one.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
Throw place.
Well,
the other thing is you get to know,
like I get to know people when they have
kids.
Your kids become friends with their kids
and then you meet the pain.
You think the parents are normal and it
turns out now,
you know,
there were actors that gave it up and
sells fucking computers or whatever.
It's like everyone had this dream.
Absolutely come out here.
It's,
I think if you,
if you,
if you just took into account all
showbiz aspirations in southern
California,
saw it on a map,
like a little red light would go off
wherever the show biz aspirations where
it'd be overwhelming.
It would be.
Whereas in places like Philly or Boston
where I'm from,
you don't see much.
It's not.
Nah,
not anyone with anyone with aspirations.
It's sort of self contained.
Yeah.
You know,
and they,
they do what's necessary.
But you know,
it's uh,
it's just,
I've always been intrigued because La
and New York are those places where
everyone you ask is from there,
you know what I mean?
Like,
no,
the girl walking down the street and
Manhattan is from Iowa,
right.
She wants to be a model or whatever.
And it's like,
same thing out here,
like,
oh,
I'm from,
you know,
from where,
like nobody's from here.
Well not nobody but very few.
Very few.
It's a total transient city.
You know,
in New York is a weird one too because
whenever I'm in New York I go,
I look at all these people go,
okay,
how do you afford this?
I just see a small walking down the
street and I'm like,
Yo,
a closet here is like five grand a month
and you just look.
It looks like you just walked out of a
shoe or like a chug.
I don't understand it.
I don't either.
And I've talked to people that lived
there in the nineties and it's still
live there today.
They're like New York City used to be a
lot of artists and a lot of like weird
people.
Especially downtown now.
It's all finance people.
It's just so gentrified.
It doesn't look like the New York that
we,
you know,
we used to centrify to fund name for
white people.
Right?
It is,
that's what it is.
Right.
It's sure it's happening in philly too.
Why is that?
Yeah.
Why these bum Russia and places that I
used to hang out with,
you had to speak Spanish to be there and
it was the hood and now it's like white
people walking.
They looked like they were in weezer
walking little like it's fucking hard to
murder scene.
Well that's a weird thing.
Like DC has that to dcs weird in that
the hood and the gentrified
neighborhoods are like a block away from
Philly is and these motherfuckers are
going to walk one block or the wrong way
and be fucking beheaded by luck.
Have at it man.
I guess you know,
how does that work?
It's just people go there for like some
sort of a professional gig and they run
out of real estate,
so they just start redoing houses.
Yeah,
man.
It's like,
it's basically like glorified slum Lord
Shit.
Like you know,
and,
and you can't,
you can't displace poor people.
It's not like they just disappear like
everyone's got to go somewhere.
You know what I mean?
So you're just like,
you're basically paying,
playing tetris with humans.
Like moving.
This was one of the worst hoods in
Philly and now it's Bougie.
Is that really happening?
Absolutely man.
Absolutely.
Like the only city more gentrified than
New York is Philadelphia in my epic.
That's happening in Brownsville,
right?
Yeah.
I mean you start going to the East New
York and Brownsville and bed stuy.
You're talking bench die do or die and
now there's like a white guys named chip
walking around.
It's like,
what's happening?
So strange.
It's bizarre.
Gentrification.
Just bizarre in general because I'm
like,
Yo,
where are you putting the people that
are leaving?
Where are they going?
Well,
who's responsibilities if you like,
if you wanted to buy a building,
are you supposed to think about the
people that are poor that are there?
He's supposed to think about your money
that you're buying the building for the
people that want to do it have to be cut
from a different cloth.
Cut from.
I couldn't do that.
Just displaced people don't.
It's just you have to.
There's a cutthroat mentality that's
needed and edits needed in the um,
the music and entertainment industry
that I don't have and it's probably held
me back by being just like a good guy
there.
Shit,
I shouldn't.
So,
like in what way,
what should,
what could you have done that would have
propelled you further?
Um,
well,
as far as far as like,
as far as being more popular,
I don't know,
but decisions I've made,
like when,
when you said,
um,
you know,
you would pay for your buddies to come,
and I do too.
Now if we had like a financial advisor,
they'd be like,
you two are morons for doing that.
I would tell them these wrong.
I'll be performing better,
so it'd be better.
Shows like my lawyer is like,
you're the worst client ever.
You pay everyone you'll pay them to.
Well you pay them to handsomely.
Fuck everybody.
And I'm like,
Yo man.
Like I don't know if that helps you get
by the.
I don't think that really advances you.
Like if you have that mentality,
I think what advances you is great work
and what is fair?
What does it take to make great work?
I think there's got to be a certain
amount of.
You have to have a certain amount of
chaos but also a certain amount of
peace.
Yeah,
of course.
You know,
you get those from the decisions that
you've made that I've made that
ultimately get made them because that's
who you are.
Yeah.
Well I think in order for me to have
altered who I am,
then I would have had to live with that
too.
Yeah.
And I don't want to not be who I am
because if I,
I wouldn't want to do the success,
would it mean anything to me if I got
there by not being me?
You gotta live with that and that's
worse than not succeeding to me.
I don't know about other people.
A lot of people just fake it and they're
not who they are and they're okay with
that.
If it comes with success in order for me
to shift who I am inherently my fiber of
my being,
the way that I was raised to treat
people,
if I had to shift that and have success,
the success wouldn't be success to me.
It won't be on paper,
but not business is just so strange.
Right.
And I don't know how you feel about
mumble rap,
but mumble rap is one of the weirdest
things.
To me.
It's.
I'm confused.
It's bizarre.
It's bizarre what is happening.
I just,
I feel like I feel like I don't want to
be that dude who doesn't get it right.
You know what I mean?
You don't get it.
I don't,
I don't get it either.
I don't.
But when you start dealing with youth
culture and when I was the age of these
mumble rap kids,
they were older heads saying,
yeah,
you know,
the,
the generation before roster,
the cold crush brothers to the big daddy
kane.
So they probably thought what we were
doing was crazy.
So is that what's happening?
I don't know.
Maybe everyone's like,
what the fuck is that?
It's like I,
I,
it's to the point where me,
where I'm like,
Yo,
is that even a genre of rap?
Like I almost look at it.
I guess I don't.
I guess I don't have a problem with it
because I don't process it.
Is anything close to what I do.
It's almost like if you said,
Yo,
what do you think about Edm?
I'd be like,
oh,
I don't know.
I guess it's all right.
It's right.
Right.
I don't even look at it like I can't
listen to that.
And then let him hear big daddy Kane and
think it's the same thing when we were
kids listening to music.
Right.
If you were listening to something that
you enjoyed,
one of the things you loved was like
good lyrics of course,
and when you can't understand what
they're saying.
Yeah.
It's also,
it's just so driven by,
if it's like phrase driven,
they just say whatever the learning over
and over and over again.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's just because these
kids are doing my alley or whatever and
they're just in the zone is a drug
culture because that's happened before
Tuesday.
You know,
one thing creates the other.
It's like chicken or the egg.
Are these kids doing molly and make
mumble rap or they don't mumble rap and
they eat molly and it's all,
it's,
you know,
the sixties,
you going back to the fifties and
beatniks in that scene and jazz and
heroin and w w what created it,
you know what I mean?
That miles and Coltrane make some of
those records because they were on
heroin or vice versa.
And it's happened historically.
Is this just a drug driven culture?
I don't know because I,
it's,
I'm detached.
You know,
I'm detaching and I,
and you know,
I'm,
I'm a kid who grew up,
you know,
listening to metal and stuff like that.
So I,
I don't,
I'm not at a shortage for.
I'll listen to slayer,
I'll just listen to slayer before I
listened to that.
If that's my only option,
then I'll listen to slayer.
You know what I mean?
I listen to black flag,
I'll listen to minor threat.
That's what I'll do it.
So there,
whether I,
however I feel about it,
it becomes irrelevant when you realize
that you have so much good shit out
there.
So I don't need.
It's like with film,
like I'm not worried about a bad movie.
I just watched the dope movie.
There's so many movies and just throwing
them away.
Right.
And it's like,
Yo,
I'll just listen to thin lizzy if I,
if I don't feel like adjusting to that,
you know what I mean?
And,
and there's other things that we might
not get because we're not doing what we
used to do.
Maybe it really were.
I was a bar of the clubs five nights a
week and you weren't married with kids
and we were hired.
Maybe it sounds different right at the
time and place.
Shit.
It's like you hear certain songs and
you're like,
I'm not listening to my car.
I'm rolling the windows up.
If someone sees this,
but maybe hit it affects them
differently in a live environment and
something.
I don't know.
I'm playing devil's advocate just just
to.
It's just a strange trend where it's a
lot of mumbling.
I'm like,
what is.
I don't know what they're on about cough
syrup.
Yeah.
I think it's just lean and I.
and I think that that,
that drug culture created that I think a
friend of mine who's a real estate
agent,
a mumble rapper was working in the house
and she's like,
I literally had no idea what the fuck he
was saying.
Oh,
he's talking to him and him talking as a
human.
As my momma just momma see.
I didn't know that.
I thought it was like that style on when
they arrive,
but maybe was just this one,
which she was showing them this dope
house and he's mumbling up a storm.
Wow.
So he's like asking her for Jacuzzi and
she thinks she's ordering a pizza.
I don't know what I mean.
I,
you know,
I love listening to Nas and I love
listening to public enemy and clean
lyrics.
Then had had a hit to them.
Karen.
One big daddy can.
Of course.
That's,
that's,
that's the police.
There was,
there was something to it though,
that you knew that they were trying to
get a message across along with the
music.
It was something cool about it.
Yeah.
I think.
I think maybe these kids think you can't
do both in our era was different.
It's like if people could dance to
public enemy and they were talking about
what was going on and urban community
that,
that Arab.
You could.
There were,
there were boogie down production,
krs records.
You could dance the sounds of the
police.
You out of here,
you could dance.
I think there was a.
there's a disconnect with these kids.
They don't think you can say something
and I have people dance or whatever.
I don't know what these fucking Momma.
Motherfucker just slobber on the corner.
It's just.
Well,
they all have to have tattoos on their
face.
It's like another mockery that tattoo
settled down.
Man.
You know,
they don't come off right.
Like I think these kids think they can
come off.
I don't think they care.
I just don't think they care.
I don't think they're thinking.
I mean it's all this.
I don't give a fuck culture.
It's like you just.
And they're not trying to get cool shit
on their face that trying to get like
scribbles.
Yeah.
It looks like the drawing,
the face of the drunk aided the party.
That's where they all look like,
you know,
they all look like that with pink
dreads.
There's a lot of rap music that slip
through the cracks too.
Like a lot of people forget about
gangstarr.
Yeah.
And one of the greatest groups ever.
You know,
but it's like,
it's,
it becomes the responsibility of the
culture to uphold that.
Like when someone like Mitch Hedberg who
passed away young,
someone like Bill Hicks,
it's like the,
the,
the comedic community is their
responsibility that those guys don't get
forgotten.
And it's the same with hip hop.
It's my responsibility to talk about
gangstarr interviews.
So the 16 year old kid says,
oh,
I'll check that out.
It's my responsibility to say,
talk about Big Daddy Kane and Kool g rap
and these dudes so people can call g rap
a lot of people forget about is the
greatest of all time.
He was one of the greatest for sure I,
I've listened to so much of his shit.
To me,
he's the best ever cock blocking just
ignorance at its finest.
Scott says,
guy says,
oh,
stand up and wipe his dick on your curt
might be the best rap lyrical wall time,
but people forgot about Kool g rap.
But if you thinking about like Hex,
right?
So he was 33 and that was like 93.
You know,
there's young kids that love comedy that
don't know about billing.
Like he influenced my life because
towards the end he was doing more social
commentary than anything.
It wasn't even,
it wasn't even that funny.
It wasn't just,
it was just like he was expanding his
mind.
He felt like talking about it and,
and Hedberg was brilliant.
Like,
you know,
it's,
it's our responsibility to carry the
torch of,
of all these people that were great
minds that left too soon.
What Bourdain?
I don't want people to forget about that
guy.
You know what I'm saying?
You special.
Well,
luckily we have a lot of shows to watch.
Yeah.
His show was so unique too because of
his narration was going to be
interesting.
I have,
uh,
the newest one with a w Kamau bell.
I haven't watched that yet,
but it apparently is the last one where
he does narration.
Oh,
okay.
And then all the other ones for this
season was after he died.
Someone else?
No,
no,
no.
They're not going to do any narration.
There's gonna.
Let the show play itself out.
Just be what it is.
They're going to do it I guess somehow
with editing and they're going to figure
it out.
But man,
it's tough man.
Another punk rock guy too.
Oh yeah,
man.
That guy went in the hall,
He went hold Jay.
Yeah.
If you look at him from 2014 and then
look at him for 2018,
like he lived several decades inside of
a few years.
He went hard.
Yeah.
I don't know if I recommend it,
but you know,
I mean
he said it best.
You know,
life.
You should treat life like treat your
body like it's an amusement park.
He did.
Yeah,
I did.
I mean there's something that we,
all we all have in common with all these
artists is that there's an understanding
that we have,
that they're all living this w,
w we nonstandard way of getting through
this life that they're all living this,
this strange,
chaotic way and creating these amazing
things through these strange,
chaotic existence and we all cling to it
and celebrate it and,
and look at it.
I mean,
whether it's Henry Rollins who travels,
he hit,
you know,
his crazy thing.
He said as a pick a spot on the map and
travel and stay there for a couple of
weeks.
He doesn't even know anybody that goes
there or whether it's Bordain who would
make these shows about it or whether
it's musicians or comedians or anybody
who does these things.
It's like we.
I think I take comfort in the fact that
there's guys like you out there and that
everybody's not trying to be some
cardigan wearing button down fake
progressive who's just trying to not
have people mad at him.
So was trying to say the things that you
think you're supposed to say so that
everybody likes you and then before you
know it,
you're dead.
There's no rebellion.
No,
no personal,
real objective opinions on things and
everything.
Great.
That's ever comments come out of a
valley.
Yeah.
It's come out of a fuck you.
If something,
if not a fuck you fuck me.
Fuck.
What is this?
What are we doing?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Fuck my life.
Fuck yeah,
and this.
If I don't know what I'm doing,
then I have to explore everything I can
to try to figure out what I'm doing.
You know what I mean?
That's the only way.
It's the only way to learn is to,
to live in,
to say I don't know what I'm doing and
then,
and then live in a bubble is the
antithesis of how to fix that.
Yeah.
You know,
and you know the,
the beautiful thing is that a guy like
you or me or other people that are
living in these different alternative
lives,
the other thing they do is they send a
signal to that kid who's sitting in his
room right now.
His parents are yelling at him because
he's got all ds and he's like,
I can't fucking do this,
but you know what I really liked to do?
I really liked to listen to rap or
really like to listen,
to stand up for.
I really like to do whatever the fuck it
is.
I really like to read books.
I just don't want him telling that kid.
It's okay.
Is an important part of what we do.
Huge.
The system that they have set up for you
when you go through this bullshit
education process,
then next thing you know,
you're in some fucking factory job or
some nonsense cubicle that is not good.
Right.
And they're not telling you that,
that,
that educational system,
they're not telling you anything.
They're not telling you about finance,
they're not telling you about diet.
They're not telling,
you know,
think what we learned in high school and
how it applies to our life.
Almost nothing,
nothing was.
No.
It's literally like giving you an engine
with not giving you driving and,
and,
and think of what they could be doing to
prepare you.
It's out there like why aren't you
giving these kids Kafka or Nietzsche or
why aren't you telling him that this is
terrible for you or this is filled with
chemicals or this is information that
needs to be out there.
You know,
I don't,
I have in terms of did you have a
learning about money when you have
nothing,
you have to have it.
Pay Your bills.
Yeah,
I know.
That might be job.
I.
Yeah.
Don't be a loser.
You're right.
That's all I know.
Fuck.
And then how am I going to do that?
Because I don't want to do that.
I don't want to be in a cubicle.
I know that.
So how do I maneuver this?
What do I do?
Nobody knows.
And if you tell people you want to try
something different,
like I want to be a rapper,
a fuck about it,
man.
Forget about.
Yes.
Yeah.
So you're fighting,
you're not just fighting the machine.
You're fighting people that love you.
Yeah.
They don't want you to be a loser.
And,
and it's,
it's,
you're trying to do the opposite of
that.
You're trying to change.
You're trying to break the cycle of
this,
you know this,
you know,
you go to school,
then you get a job where you go to
school,
then you go to college and then you get
into $250,000
worth of debt to go work a job.
You hate to pay off that $250,000
debt.
And it's the cycle and that's what the
country,
the cycle of this country and the fucked
up thing is if you want to do something
different,
nobody's there.
We've got a path for you.
Like if you say,
Hey,
you know,
I really love hip hop,
I want to be a rapper,
then no one says,
oh,
well that's a viable job opportunity.
Obviously a lot of people are rappers.
You can do this.
This is something you could do.
No one says that.
Nobody.
No one.
No.
If you tell them you want to be a
standup,
what are you fucking out of your mind?
You're not funny.
My mom told me that.
Wow.
I never thought you were very funny.
Alright mom,
I'd talk shit about you and all the
people laugh and the weightlifting skit.
You did that.
That was me and Brian Collins.
Brilliant.
Yeah.
But this alternative lives like outside
of the straight and narrow structure
that most people follow that's available
to people.
They just have to.
They have to have more examples of it.
It's,
it's example.
If people like us are examples and they
also.
There is though,
I will say this,
um,
you have to have balls,
yes,
to do it and you have to be able to look
at things,
honestly.
Things that aren't of course,
right.
That shit I didn't do.
I wasn't,
um,
I wasn't being self aware at certain
times.
And then once you start doing that and
saying maybe this is me,
maybe this is me,
and if I change this and you see instant
results,
you know what I mean.
How long have you been doing it for A.
I wrote my first rhyme at nine,
but it was like the worst thing ever.
What was your early influences?
Uh,
the car?
Well,
my brothers brought home suck MCS that
was 83.
It was like little.
I played on like muppets a turntable.
And uh,
the first record where I said I want to
rap was a latte.
This cuts got flavor.
I was like,
I want to do this.
And then I did a member candy girl by
new edition.
I did.
I wrapped on that at the end,
like third grade talent show.
Really?
Yeah.
Bird.
Great.
My Mom's got it on vhs and threatens me
with it.
I'm like,
that's not a threat.
I put it off.
Got To threaten me with that.
When I was in junior high school,
I heard Sugar Hill gang for the very
first time.
It's like life changing.
I remember thinking,
Whoa,
this is a new kind of music is a new
thing.
Hip Hop and hippie creativity,
hip hop activity beat.
Don't stop a rocket to the bank.
Jumped buggy.
Crazy.
Yeah.
I mean I remember thinking like,
wow,
this is a new thing.
Yeah.
And then when run DMC was so hard with
sucker MCS,
Yo,
what the fuck is this?
Because she'll get hell.
I obviously love that.
Reagan changed the course of the history
but they were rhyming over the sheik
instrumental,
you know,
so,
but when suck just those drums,
those hard drugs.
And then being from Philly,
like hearing school a day and like,
you know,
got these hard records.
But like first time,
first time,
like I rhymed,
like to record something like um,
like 90 91,
you know,
and it was awful,
you know.
But.
So you just work on your craft and hope
that you get to a point where people
don't think you're awful.
When did you start getting paid?
Um,
let me see.
So we put out an APP on our own that we
pressed up in [inaudible] 96 and I'm
like,
where I was like,
I'm living off wrap.
Does that weigh 98,
98?
Um,
but what kind of jobs do you have a
before you.
I didn't really have jobs.
I like,
I'm a dirt bag.
Therapeutic Shit.
Yeah,
for a couple years after high school,
just,
just some scumbag shit.
And then the first check came and I was
like,
there's no turning back now man.
You know what I mean?
This is the greatest shit ever.
Like money from what you wanted to buy
Jordans from rapping.
What are you talking about?
Yeah,
blew my fucking mind,
man.
You know,
blew my mind.
Like,
you know,
buying a pair of Jordans with that.
With that.
It's unreal.
But yeah,
like never a.
If I can die never having a square gigs,
I consider it a success.
Yeah.
When did you really say to yourself,
okay,
I'm a legit professional now,
like this is it.
There's no turning back.
I'm 100 percent now.
Like I don't have to worry about this
going away.
I still don't think that really it,
it's the fear again.
It's the fear of like the second I think
that it'll go away.
You know what I mean?
Things get bigger.
Our office gets bigger,
the,
you know,
the merge business grows the,
towards growing.
I'm still,
the fear is,
is like Yo,
I'm,
I'm just lucky.
I just feel lucky that I'm able to do
it.
So I never want to think that way.
You know?
I guess I have to answer the question.
If someone,
a stranger says,
what do you do?
You know,
I have to answer it because it is what I
do and I made a lot of money and I'm
good.
My mom's good because of it,
you know?
But I feel like the day that I,
I feel like that,
that,
that may be a,
I don't know,
you know,
like the philosophy when a,
when a fight is thinking of retirement,
it means there were two,
they're already retired and I am sort of
applying that logic.
Like the second I say,
Yo,
this is my thing,
you know,
I could play for 75,000
kids in a festival in Switzerland.
I still,
I'm still standing on a piece of
garbage,
you know,
and that sort of like withdrawing.
It's sort of a driving thing with me,
you know what I mean?
Whereas,
you know,
historically rapids just been so ego
driven.
I'm the bad stuff.
That's the cornerstone of it when you
Ryan.
But some people carry themselves like
that in real life,
you know,
and I don't want to be that man.
You know,
it's like I'm so,
I'm so scared of someone ever thinking
that humility isn't the most important
thing to me.
And being polite is the most important
thing to me,
you know?
And it is.
And that's not really how people are in
this game,
you know?
And,
and,
and not just a wrap,
just the entertainment business and they
don't meet an actor who's addicted like,
Yo,
man,
you get paid to act.
You get,
that's a blessing.
We're lucky to be here.
Right here.
I'm,
I'm just blessed to be sitting here with
you man.
So why would I,
why would I be anything but appreciative
of that?
And I don't want to think,
oh,
this is what I do.
I just want to like live in,
in the moment.
Yeah.
Maybe when it's over I'll tell you,
Yo,
I was a tour.
If you say you're not going to tour
again,
do you mean you want tour
internationally or you want tour?
Will you still perform locally?
Like what are you going to do?
Well,
the,
I just landed a yesterday from so that
we did,
we started in Baltimore,
Baltimore,
New York,
Philly,
Boston,
have a mind and to,
to sell out your hometown.
Then it's like this many years later,
you know,
and to sell out in New York and sell out
Boston.
It's this thing,
that way it's still fucking mind
blowing.
You know what I mean?
And it's still people cheering your
name,
it's mine,
but I just,
maybe I just,
maybe it's more of like sometimes people
need to decompress and maybe I just need
to decompress for a little bit and I
completely changed my mind and just not
just,
not toward next year or something,
you know?
And then maybe I'll be ready or
something.
It's just,
I love walking out on that stage.
Man.
I love being out here talking to you.
I love you.
I was with be real yesterday from Cyprus
doing his stuff.
I love all the smoke box.
I would lose my fucking brain.
It was just him in there with that Bro.
Well I don't have to tell you they were
smoking heavy.
I think I walked out zonked.
Just being in the room with them.
I'm sure.
Yeah,
I was zapped.
Yeah.
He's one of those all day,
dude.
I can't do that.
Yes sir.
Have too much stuff to do.
Yeah,
sure.
Of course.
He's getting shit done though.
Is one of those rare individuals can
stay stoned,
but uh,
yeah,
no,
I just,
I think maybe some decompression I like,
I think like a and Dante circles of
hell.
I think airports might be on there.
There's loads of them.
I hate the whole process of checking in
like this.
That's like,
you know,
people,
God bless people who have that private
jet money that Elon Musk money,
you know what I'm saying?
Like we did.
But that's wasting your,
you're burning off all that cash short.
Like if you're making 100 and spending
40 on the jet like Shit,
man.
To know indeed.
It's just um,
the,
the process man.
It's when you were talking about being
alone in hotel rooms.
I hate,
I hate the hurry up and wait of all of
the entertainment industry and that's
what it's built around.
You know,
it's still trips me out when I wake up
in the morning and look at the ceiling
and I don't remember where I am.
Yo.
Ohio?
No.
Yes.
Silly.
No,
no,
no.
Yes,
yes.
Oh,
like,
Yo,
what country am I in?
Yeah,
it's fucked.
It's fucked.
It's weird.
It's very weird.
Do you think when you take the time off,
are you gonna still right?
And you get a storm in the studio?
I write,
I write five days a week and I record
every Thursday,
every Thursday.
Every Thursday.
Yeah.
So you write five days a week now what's
your process like?
How do you write?
It has to be super late at night.
Um,
yeah I can't,
I really can't do anything during the
day.
MMM.
Just a nocturnal by nature.
Um,
I just sit there with a beat blasting.
Just sit there.
Yeah,
let it come.
One Bar,
one bar,
one bar
until it's done.
So do you have like a raw beet with no
lyrics and then.
Yeah.
So who,
who makes a beat for your first um,
that I worked with a lot of producers.
So when those send them and when I love
something I go,
all right,
I'm going to work on this tonight.
You know,
so you get the beat and then,
and then you sit and listen to it and
you start thinking about things.
Exactly.
Ah,
what's the hardest thing for me as the
first line?
Whereas the hardest thing,
I'm,
they're the authors say this exactly,
he hit him.
I'm sure.
I mean the first joke probably hard
because everything goes off of that,
you know what I mean?
So it's that,
that line is super hard.
Um,
and then I,
I,
I love being in the studio.
I love it.
The whole,
that's where I would be,
um,
unfortunately because when we were kids
records sold,
right?
So you could be like,
I don't want a tour,
I'm fucking,
I'm the,
were the Beatles.
We sold fucking $100,000,000
because we don't have to tour.
They just decided they didn't want a toy
at 67 and they never did again.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
But,
but it's,
everything is generated monetarily
through touring,
merge,
you know what I mean?
So it's like the grind is there and I
don't like to feel like my hand is
forced ever because that,
that's when it starts.
That's that square world.
And I never want to feel like I'm
obligated to do something and that can
be some of my animosity towards Tori.
You know what I mean?
Like,
you know,
this is what you do,
this is what you have to do,
you know,
go out this many days.
That's just this.
Like,
it's,
it's just uh,
it just fries my brain,
man,
you know,
I know obviously all this shit takes a
physical toll on you,
but if it fries my brain where I'm like
just completely zonked.
Like I'm a walking through life.
I never know.
Like I never see anything.
People are like,
how is Blah Blah Blah.
The how is the loop.
I'm like,
I never saw that shit.
You know,
like how is the blah blah blah.
And they all the same shit man.
It's like,
oh,
how was Bob?
I never saw shit man.
Nothing ever.
No room venue,
hotel rooms,
van or box or whatever.
You know what I mean?
It's ran,
repeat,
rinse,
repeat.
You know,
and people,
you know,
people like I said,
like I think it just the entertainment
business in general,
it's,
there's a,
there's a perception that it isn't work
because it's not the work that they do.
Like try working on a car all day.
I'm like,
try driving 15 hours with someone who
smells like balls in a tour van or you
know,
like,
or try to take it though,
right?
I mean you'll take it over a regular
course when you write,
do you write with a pencil and paper?
Do you write in your head?
Do you write on a computer?
I uh,
I wrote in a rhyme book just like a
spiral Ryan Book for you for all my
adult life.
And then I started not being able to
read my hand writing.
I write like a graffiti writer and I'd
be like,
what's this word?
So now I go,
what I do,
I go over my head when I have enough,
when I have enough,
I'll type it out,
you know?
And then like go with my hat on my head
and type it out.
Now it's like clean and organized,
which is not me know on any level.
How long have you been doing it that
way?
Really recent.
Like how was her?
Was it a year real?
Yeah.
And do you write like on Microsoft word
or something like A.
I don't even know what it is,
just like a note thing on the computer.
It's called like notepad or something.
Okay.
Yeah.
But like on a Mac or a PC,
but,
but that wouldn't go writing five days a
week and go into the recording every
Thursday.
Only started when I stopped the heavy
drinking.
Like everything changed.
Everything changed because you,
you,
you don't want to be creative when
you're hungover,
you don't want to,
you want to sleep,
you know what I mean?
So like I,
I recorded more in the past two years
than the previous time.
Yeah man.
Yeah.
I have tons of music recorded,
you know,
maybe it's not all great but it's
recorded,
you know,
and I'm writing and have clarity,
on a lot of levels.
Is there any window that you could see
opening up or you can make money from
the actual music itself because it,
this is a,
I mean the last couple of decades
through the music business on its head,
but their streaming services now.
And Jamie was just talking about the
thing that Steven Tyler was talking
about.
It's called music modernization act.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's the thing where they're trying to
get the streaming companies because
they're giving you a pittance.
Well,
Pandora,
that just sold for billions of dollars
and it's like,
what do you do?
Right?
You're worth billions of dollars when
you do,
you distribute other people's art.
You don't really have,
don't pay them.
You don't pay them,
you make all the money.
You're talking to save pennies on the
dollar.
Wouldn't be enough.
I'm not exaggerating.
It's no.
Um,
I'm not sure if either one of you guys
saw the tweet from um,
a crosby from crosby,
stills and Nash.
I didn't see it.
It was like a break down of what he got
paid for.
You know,
how huge those records were.
So it was like $55 or something for,
for like $200 million streams.
And then Peter Frampton responded to him
with another screenshot and it's like,
here's mine.
And I have one of the biggest records
ever.
Peter Frampton comes alive and they were
going back and forth and like people in
the industry will re tweeting it because
I mean these are guys sure,
a older and be richer than we can ever
imagine and it's important for people
like them to speak up.
Like was.
I repeat the streamers,
don't pay us for the damned music that
we made in all caps.
Don't pay us this David Crosby and a few
tweets that are similar.
Yeah,
there's one with the actual numbers and
the.
Yeah,
I mean it's stunning and I don't
understand how they're getting away with
it.
I don't either.
I don't either and I'm not powerful
enough to do that.
That's why I do like him.
Like at one point Taylor swift pulled
all our shit and I was like,
that's great because she's huge.
That's an important statement.
You know what I mean?
It's like if,
if you guys weren't getting paid
correctly from a streaming service for
you stand up and someone like Eddie
Murphy spoke up,
that's important.
A fucking a hack and Schenectady
tweeting about it won't let them put my
podcast on the and they've been trying
to do it for years and I'm saying,
no.
Yeah.
What,
what do I get out of it?
Well,
it's just another way for people to get
your,
you know,
there's a lot of people that are
listening.
People are already listening to that
shit happens to me.
What will you do this?
No.
And they're blown away that you say no.
And again,
that's why I think your punk rock,
whether you do it not,
you just say fuck you.
Well I just understand what they're
doing.
They're thieves and they want to put ads
on it and they in the most recent thing
is that they'll give you some money,
but like now compared to what you're
making,
what are you going to do?
All you have is other people's work,
right?
Other than that,
you just have a,
a bus station.
I'm,
I feel bad for p.
you've built your own everything,
your,
your own entity.
I've done the same thing on a smaller
level where we're,
we're outliers,
bro.
Like some people really need that shit
though,
you know what I mean?
Like when they get stuck in the system
and then even worse they become a part
of some sort of a network where they
have a bunch of executives telling them
what they do is sign those major label
deals that are in the videos with the
jewelry and shit.
None of that shit.
It's either fake,
it's rented.
Those cars are rented.
You know what I mean?
There's still living in the projects and
then they're in those videos with land.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like perceptions become reality
through social media.
So people think like,
you know,
you have a rented car and ran the
jewelry on that,
you're worth this.
And I'm like,
Yo,
you don't know the fuckery that,
that label over them.
He's got a three 60 deal they've taken
is merge.
They're taking this.
That's what's crazy.
Did it take your merge and your ticket
sales company that doesn't have anything
to do with you performing,
they take a piece of you performed this?
Yes.
And these things that like things are
offered to me and I'm like,
Yo man,
I spent my entire life building this and
you,
you want a piece of the pie that I baked
for no reason I'll share with anybody,
but what's the reason for it?
But you got to be offering something,
bring something to the table.
They're,
they're not bringing anything to the
table.
What are they saying that we can make
you bigger?
We'll get you on the radio,
which nobody listens to anymore.
Like what are they saying right now?
This is the radio,
not me.
Is there any.
What is,
is there a big radio station these days
that anybody listens to?
Not that I'm aware of.
I mean,
I know they still exist.
I know that hot 97 still in New York,
but I don't have anyone listens to it.
But where the kids find out about music
now it's got to be through the Internet.
It's there.
The interwebs.
Uh,
I asked the kid,
a young barber was cutting me and he was
like,
what do you do?
You musicians like casually got into it.
And I was just making conversation,
I was like,
how do you listen to music?
He was like spotify,
apple music and soundcloud.
And I was like,
okay.
I don't use any of the three of them,
but yeah.
But it's good to know,
you know what I mean?
It's like
it's who,
uh,
like I listened.
I have your podcast on like in a podcast
app on my phone,
you know what I mean?
And I'm assuming that's what people do.
It's a little bit easier to track I
suppose.
But again,
it's like the Peter Frampton and David
crosby thing.
Like I said,
it was some number that's outlandish,
like 200 million streams or something.
Any 50 bucks.
Like how,
how is that criminals,
how is it legal?
It shouldn't be.
They,
they rigged the system they have.
Did they have to figure out a way to
quantify it the same way?
Record sales would have been like when
we went to the fucking store,
when we went to tower records of the mom
and pop store or whatever it goes.
That's it.
Recent numbers per scream.
Napster was rhapsody zero point zero,
one nine titles,
zero point zero,
one,
two,
five apple music.
So you get your song played a million
times and get less than $5.
Seems Fair.
He said that's fucking insane.
Million streams.
You get less than five clams.
Man,
that is insane.
It's so small.
Is Youtube zero point zero,
zero zero six nine.
Is that.
What is that?
That's fucking insane.
One hundred 60 $900,000.
100.
That's a hard word to say.
100 thousandths of a dollar.
Can you even quantify that as money at
that point?
What?
What does anyone do when they.
They're faced with this sort of
information like is anything going to
change and if it does change,
what are they going to double it?
That's what I mean.
That's 10 bucks.
That's my worry that it's being brought
to people's attention and it might go
to,
you know,
the big government might get involved
and how much is that going to shift?
Right?
Well the artists can't pull the music.
The music is owned by the record
companies.
The record companies are going to play
it and they're not going to pay them the
same.
They would pay someone who is buying it.
Right.
I know Taylor swift pulled her shit for
a minute on some making a stance,
but however it was rectified,
she put it back.
I gave her money probably.
I'm sure they gave her money.
Yeah.
They give people money.
They're giving people money for podcasts
too.
They give you money for like exclusive
use of it for a couple days like that,
but like for two days or something along
those lines or they want to put their
own ads on it.
Those lines.
But people can get your podcasts.
You don't need
to do that.
Oh Man.
You just letting someone make some money
off you for no reason.
Absolutely.
Absolutely,
and will end what we do.
It's like we control our shit.
Why would we give that up?
Yeah.
Tell me why.
That's what they needed to tell me.
Why I would give up control of my shit
too.
You can't.
There's no logical explanation unless
we're talking fucking money and y'all
ain't turn on your music.
You see,
that's nice.
That's nice.
And there's not a lot of people that can
say that.
No,
because you know,
you know,
when you sign with a major they own your
masters.
So it's like you can't do it,
you know,
if I want to,
an album of mine that came out in 2010,
say 20 slash 20,
I want to do a 10th anniversary edition
on Blue Vinyl and all that kind of cool
shit.
I can I ask anybody?
Right.
It's like direct to consumer ship is
basically what I'm doing and my merged
companies run,
you know,
I try to do that as much as possible
because I'm,
that diy aesthetic is important to me.
You know what I mean?
It's,
you know,
we grew up with people and that they
seemed untouchable,
you know,
Rockstar Shit,
superheroes,
you know what I mean?
I would like to sort of bridge that gap
where it's like,
no,
I'll come up and say what's up man?
You know what I mean?
Let's talk.
How are you,
you know,
what your name.
Do you still sell actual physical cds
anymore?
Yeah,
we do.
Because there's a niche audience man,
that like how many people buy them is
that.
It's like,
well,
see,
I press vinyl.
I press tapes before,
but just to be,
just to be cute.
Could be cute.
Joseph.
Uh,
yeah.
Tapes,
vinyl CDs and Vinyl sells the most love
vinyl.
Yes.
Right.
Yeah.
It's a big,
big comeback.
Cds still that they're the most honestly
right now today tapes are more popular
than CDS.
Like a nostalgia thing and it'll
probably go away,
but like we discussed,
not even pressing them.
Wow.
Yeah.
Like that's how much I did because I'm
old school,
but we discussed like not doing it,
but vinyl still coming in strong.
You buy into the sound difference.
I do,
yeah.
Yeah.
But I buy into it with first you have to
start at the source,
like if it's recorded amazingly,
then if it sounds Shitty,
it's gonna Sound Shitty.
I'd rather listen to the Beatles on
vinyl.
I ran,
listen to.
I listen to thin lizzy on vinyl,
metal,
stuff like that.
I mean a lot of,
a lot of hip hop shit.
You know,
kids have a mic and a laptop in the
bedroom and that's the,
that's the recording studio.
That's not gonna make any fucking
difference is going to be what it is,
you know what I mean?
But bands through care.
I,
it's,
it's warmer.
Like if I listen to stevie wonder
records said warmer.
Warmer.
Yeah.
I've heard that expression before.
I don't know really how to articulate
it,
but in my head I know what it means.
Just the baselines and drums.
Everything sounds warm to me.
Can they replicate that?
It was impossible.
Some people can.
With electronics to a degree,
you still need to.
You still need to get analog to a
degree.
You know what I mean?
There's still a few studios in the
country that do shit on reel to reel
because that sound,
you can't,
you can't have a fully replicated.
You can get close,
but you need to go to a reel to real to
really get that.
You know,
we loved.
Yeah.
Now what about like apple music and
people buying things on itunes?
It's like that.
People still do that,
right?
Yeah.
But that's dropping too.
Yeah,
yeah,
it's,
it's streaming,
it's soul stream dominated,
you know,
because even when people were doing
that,
like buying albums on itunes,
buying albums digitally on Amazon or
whatever,
someone's preferences.
It was sweet.
It was good,
good money,
all of that.
And then the streaming shit like.
Because logically if you're a casual
music fan and you pay $10 a month for
spotify for every album that's ever been
recorded,
can you really blame the van?
You know what I mean?
And their ways of the ways of ingesting
music is so different.
Like I love the opening the vinyl.
I love reading the thank yous.
I love the smell of the fucking cassette
tape.
I loved it was an experience going to
the store,
being on the bus with the headphones on
the first time you hear it,
know I can tell you where I was when I,
when I bought nozzle nomadic,
where I can tell you all that.
That's the experience that it's,
you know,
boom,
Bhangra and now I have the album.
You didn't comment.
I got the new Joe Rogan album,
two seconds with a click.
That's a weird thing to me.
You know what I mean?
It's,
I guess it's not weird to them,
but the little stores you would go to
where there was little stations where
you could press a button and listen
preview of all these different and
people just stand there all day,
all day listening to music all day,
get it,
and if they didn't have them,
you were buying shit and guessing many
bad bad shit.
I was looking at cool album.
I bought out album,
like metal albums with a bad ass
covering the band was just terrible.
You know what I mean?
You see sugar man.
Yes.
How crazy is that mother fucking crate.
I don't know what's crazier at the story
or that he got big in Africa batshit.
That movie made me cry.
I've been me too bad shit.
Crazy,
but just how insane that this guy went
on to become like a laborer for a
construction company.
Had no idea that he was a superstar in
Africa.
Insane.
And then goes there as an older man to
sold out stadium and they all know the
words.
It's beautiful man.
That is one of the craziest
documentaries our time searching for
sugar,
man,
if you haven't seen it folks.
Yes.
He got to see it.
It's brilliant.
Well done.
And that's a different era too.
You know,
that guy gave all his money when I
do this is the real fucking deal or no
fucking joke,
man.
I mean he still lives like he lived when
he was a poor construction worker.
Whoa.
It's elevated Lao elevated way of
thinking.
Yeah,
I think he just got so used to being in
that space for so long and his fucking
music is good.
It's really good.
I think sometimes man,
like when that's brought on you,
you're still more comfortable in that
other way,
you know,
some people don't want to.
They're not comfortable embracing that,
you know,
whether it's wealth or fame or a mixture
of both.
I just think he was like,
I'm good content.
And there's people with billions that
aren't content,
which there's nothing more important
than being good with yourself and he
seems good with himself.
Yeah.
That is one of the scarier things.
As someone who insanely successful but
never satisfied,
I think a lot of people are like.
That was one of the things I was saying
about trump,
like if you are 70 years old and you
have billions of dollars,
why are you still working?
Yes.
What do you do?
You think something's going to change
and you're going to live forever,
right?
Do you have no perception that you
literally on the last finger full of
Greens in your hourglass,
it's all you got left and you're not
spending it on a yacht and occupied.
Getting your Dick sucked to big pimpin
in the background.
What's the.
What's the mechanism in his head?
It's this drive ennis.
I know that I think about like that
about Warren Buffet.
Yeah,
right.
Because that keeps you going.
He was like 409 years old with no,
I don't even know how much money and
he's a real weird one because he still
lives in the middle of nowhere.
He's a strange bird.
A regular house.
Yeah.
And He,
his suits always looked like they were
just pulled off the rack at a warrant.
Tailored.
Yeah.
He,
he goes to a terrence Crawford fights
always.
He's always there.
He was hanging out with floyd one night
running.
Yeah,
he.
He's he reps Nebraska.
Yeah.
Hard.
He's an interesting guy.
He was super interesting.
Yeah,
but listen man,
we just did three hours.
Believe it or not.
Thank you.
My pleasure,
brother.
I'm glad we finally got a chance,
man.
It means a lot.
A big fan for a very long time to
people.
How they can find you on twitter,
instagram,
box cutter.
Patsy on Instagram,
twitter.
It's vinny underscore pass and a
website.
JMT store.
Com.
Jedi mind tricks.
Everything's on there.
Thank you brother.
Thank you so much man.
See what happened.
Oh,
that was great.